Good. And you're good? Okay. All right.
We're going to go ahead and get started and call this meeting, our work session,
to order. It's 4:01. And Ben
is going to be here in just a minute. I think he's online for now
until he gets here. Okay. And also just wanted to
point out we do have a lot of closed session items to get
through tonight for the council's awareness. So I
want to stick as close as we can to these timelines, and we've told each
of the presenters to make sure that half the time's for the presentation
and half the time's for some discussion if that's the case. If there's something that
requires more time, then just let us know that we
needed to bring it back or something. But I want to try and make sure
that we can stay on track because we got a lot to do in,
in a minute. So. Thank you. With that in mind, I did move some
things around earlier, but I don't think it changed anything.
So we're gonna start off with 1D, discussion item 1D,
which is the Well-Being Project survey results.
So, Abby, were you gonna introduce?
Yes, thank you, Mayor. I just wanna introduce
Dr. Courtney Flint. She's a professor at Utah State University.
They did a well-being survey that was conducted in April 2021.
2026 of this year, and she's here to share the results, which I think
are really interesting. So I'm gonna turn the time over to her. Thank you for
doing this. Sure. Awesome. So great to be with you. It's great to be partners
again. We partnered with you on this project in 2020. A lot's changed
in Eagle Mountain since then, so it's fun to look at the results. I'll hop
right in. So the goals of the project, you know, I'm from Utah
State. We're the land-grant university. Any Aggies in the house?
Oh, we're far from Aggieland. Okay.
Well, it's great to be here. We really provide, with the Utah Well-Being
Project, a way to help you keep your fingers on the pulse
of how your residents are doing, inform your planning processes and
decision-making. We do some research on the data related to well-being,
and we support statewide and regional initiatives. We work closely with health
districts, Department of Health, Department of Transportation, Office of
Planning and Budget, things like that. As you can see from the map, we are
all up and down the Wasatch Front and east and west and north and south
across the state. Our city reports from our 2026
surveys are online. Yours is up on our website, so I encourage you
to check that out if you haven't already. So this is an
online survey. It is a no-cost partnership
with you, emphasis on the word partnership. This would not happen without
us working together because we provide the survey,
We provide some materials, but you do the recruitment. We figure cities know
best how to reach their residents, and we don't have the budget to do it
any other way, so this is how it works. You did participate in 2020.
You had 506 responses then, and you had 359
responses. These are all pretty comparable numbers to
other cities similar to you all.
We like to be— since it's not a proportionate representative
sampling effort, we like to be very transparent about who
we are reaching, and who we are not. So this graph here compares the survey
demographics with the demographics that we can see from recent census
data. The closer the dots are, and really you can
barely see that there are 2 dots in many of these places, what that means
is the closer the dots are means we have really, really represented
that particular demographic. So we've done actually really well
according— you look across income, Most of the age categories
here, employment and homeowners and renters,
those dots are overlapping. I mean, that's just really incredible.
We don't see that kind of correlation as well. We do
overrepresent those who are married, but we're pretty darn close
on most everything else. That 18 to 29-year-old age
group is hard to reach anyway. Mostly full-time
residents, 50% have lived here for 5
years or less. Super high when you compare it to a lot of our communities.
Communities that are in the project. I should say there were 57
other— 56 other communities that we are reporting
on this spring. So let's dive into the
results. So personal well-being in Eagle Mountain, we compare the
group at the bottom are the rapid growth cities. We use the League of Cities
and Towns caucus groups, and so
that's what we've represented here.
You may or may not sort of feel comfortable there, although you are certainly rapidly
growing. Average of 3.92, 72% said
a 4 or a 5. It ranks a little bit low here in terms of
comparing to other rapid growth cities, but you're right there with other
nearby neighbors in Saratoga Springs and in Lehigh. You're all probably
not even statistically significantly different from each other.
If you look at the big scale and you think from all the way to
the big cities to the really small towns, you can see that
there are a fair few— there's some communities that are lower than
Eagle Mountain. So don't get too hung up on your positionality there in those rapid
growth cities. And I think we've got some good explanations for why that's
the case where it is at the moment. Community well-being,
we see it always declines for respondents.
They often feel that others, the community as a whole, is not doing as well
as they are personally. So we have the data
here. 42% say a 4 or a 5.
Change over time since 2020. Now, we don't know if it's the same group taking
the survey or not, but if you look on average here, you can see that
well-being has declined somewhat since our 2020
survey data. We look beyond these general
categories and we dive into 12 different what we call domains or categories of
well-being. And this has been informed by various
federal and international agencies. You can see that here in this graph, it shows
us that the most important well-being domains to the
people of Eagle Mountain are mental health, safety and security, living standards,
and family life. The highest-rated domains
are family life, safety and security, and mental health. So really strong
alignment with those things that matter most to folks are doing really well.
So that is a that is important. The red zone,
which is those things that are important to folks but rated
a little lower than average, we find leisure time and local environmental
quality. Now leisure time, we know that your
largest age group is actually in that 30 to 39-year-old
range, and that group, as we look across the state data,
those people are not the— don't have the highest well-being.
In fact, they're really quite low, and they're really, really busy. They're often
raising families and working hard, and so leisure time is a sparse
commodity for that group. So that may explain why that's there. Local environmental
quality is the most prominent red zone
category around the state. So we all, as a state,
you're not alone in that position. And as we look at these things
over time, you can see that some of them have declined ever so slightly.
A couple more, education, local environmental quality, have that
deeper dip. over those 6 years.
Safety and security has gone up just a tad.
Another thing we measure with the wellbeing survey is community connection.
How connected do you feel to Eagle Mountain as a community?
And we see this is actually quite low here. But let's
remember that 50% of the respondents had lived
here less than 5 years or less. Well, there's not much time
for people to get a strong sense of community like some of our very
well-established communities that are also in the survey set
this year. But it does give you some benchmarks of places you
can go, and I have some data that I think will give you some,
perhaps some pointers. We can see that community
connection is very important here. We see a strong, pretty strong
correlation with overall well-being. We see it with mental health.
So, the stronger that sense of community connection, it does have a
benefit in some of these other areas of life.
There's a couple of things going on in terms of personal demographics
and well-being. Those with disabilities have lower well-being scores.
Those who are homeowners have a higher well-being
score. And we do see a bit of that correlation with income.
We see it very strongly across the data across the state.
It is certainly a signature there in your data, but perhaps not
as strong as others. Also, the community connection,
those who are not Hispanic or Latino seem
to have a lower sense of community connection here.
That is really quite— yes,
the Hispanic and Latino community has a higher sense of community connection,
and that is the reverse of most of the communities in the survey.
We also see by age, you can see those age groups in
the from 50, 40 to 50 are actually
feeling more community connected than those who are 18
to 39 or those who are 60 years and over.
Now here's one of the things we're finding quite interesting is well a
Eagle Mountain residents are really very active. They're walking,
they're biking, they're recreating in parks, they're gardening.
They are using trails in and around your city, and everywhere you
see a star, a big star there for community events,
those who attend community events have a statistically
significantly higher level of community connection. So those community events pay off
for those who participate. And then all those smaller stars, those are
still correlated, not quite as strongly as that one with community connection,
but lots of correlations there with well-being and with community connection.
And really, these things appear to be— the data are showing us that these
appear to be worth the investment. Working on your parks,
working on your trails, having these community events, having rec programs,
those who participate seem to have these higher levels of connection and
well-being. Okay, here's a striking one. Folks in Eagle
Mountain feel that the current rate of population growth is too fast.
It is not unlike some of the neighbors around here.
So Saratoga Springs bumps you out just by a little bit, but yeah,
y'all know about your 100% population
growth rate, I'm sure. That percentage
that's saying too fast has gone up in the 6 years since we did
this survey previously, and those that thought it was just right,
well, that's plummeted. So they've replaced, they've switched
from just right to too fast. Economic development,
you can see here, is a lot more mixed.
We've got 50% of folks saying it's actually
too slow, but we still have some saying just right or
too fast. The too slow folks,
about the same. They are exactly the same. The just
right folks have declined a little bit, whereas the too fast folks have come up.
So really a mixed kind of response here.
One of the things we look at is cost of living this year. For those
for whom childcare is relevant, and that looks to be
about 46% of the survey takers, that 74%
of them are saying that that is difficult or very difficult to afford.
That one's jumping out in many cities and towns.
But healthcare and housing are also right up there at nearly half of respondents
are saying those are pretty hard to afford. And you still have just under
a third or about a third saying that even food, utilities, and transportation is
is a challenge. So cost of living, not unique to Eagle Mountain, but something
that's going on. Barriers to travel, travel time,
lack of routes and cost are really quite high here compared
to most cities, even in the Wasatch Front. So you're standing out
there a bit. We ask about a lot of different concerns. This list has
grown a fair bit since you participated in 2020.
You've got traffic at the top of your list. And water supply
and water quality there. And so that's not uncommon to
be on the top, but your percentages are really quite high.
You've got a whole smattering of other things that are above 50% of
folks have a moderate or major concern on these items.
I just want to take one minor aside and say that my other hat
is I am the Associate Director of the Utah Water Research Laboratory up at Utah
State. Water is everything we do. We provide
a great deal of services across the suite of water flows and supply
through to water quality and help with wastewater treatment plants.
If you folks in engineering and in public works have any interest
in chatting with us about how we can support you in the water realms,
especially given how concerned your residents are, we would be really happy
to have that conversation. We would welcome that.
Just 2 more slides. What do people value about Eagle Mountain? They really value—
some of them clearly have a sense of community, feeling of community,
people are friendly. They value the space out here,
the quieter pace of life, and the family-oriented environment.
They do feel there's some sense of peace here, at least somebody did,
and that those trails, that sense
of connection to nature is a valued out here. What would
improve well-being? Focusing on more roads
and infrastructure to accommodate the growth. Another road in
and out they would certainly think would benefit them.
There's some— many seeking a better balance between growth
and homes. We see that in many of these rapid growth communities.
A rec center for especially folks on the On the
young age and the older age is something that we were hearing a lot
in the open comments, access to recreation areas and
making sure people know about those areas. And with that, I want
to say thank you so much for being a partner. And if I can answer
any quick questions, I would be happy to.
I will also add quickly that I have also shared all of your open comments,
and there are many of them. I think about 80% of the respondents
They've got a lot on their mind. So you have those at your disposal.
We do not share those publicly. We just share them with you.
We use a couple here and there as part of research, but the
bulk of them are yours. So one quick question. How statistically significant
do you think the survey is? Well, because we allow any
resident age 18 or older to participate, it is not based on a
probability sampling. But we know that based on your adult population and
the responses that we have here, you're looking at about a margin
of error of about 5%. But we cannot say that it
is scientifically significantly representative.
However, the demographic correlations that we saw
suggest that— and the numbers of respondents that you have— say
that I would take these results quite seriously. I can't—
because of the sampling lack of— This representative sampling,
I'm not going to go all the way to the bank, but I'm going to
say you've got some pretty good data here compared to many cities.
I was just going to say thank you for that presentation. As I was going
through it, I was like, yep, yep, yep. Like a lot of things make sense
around traffic and connections and parks and all of that.
What— you do this for many other cities. What were the,
like, the Number 1, number 2 things that
would come to the top of your list that you'd recommend our council look at?
Well, I think working on that community connection score, I think, would be
a top item. And that can vary for different folks,
what would make them feel more connected. We could probably dig
in here to your demographics a little bit more and give you more precision
on that if you're interested in that. We would be glad to follow up.
The community connection can be done through community
events, but it can also be gathering places
where people can just get to know each other a little bit better. And those
can be at the neighborhood scale. They don't necessarily have to be all the way
up here at your 30-plus thousand people's, you know,
whole community. Sometimes blooming where people are planted
can be a valuable way to foster those community connections. I'd say that would be
number one. Number one that jumps out, addressing the concerns of
residents on things like water, things like open space. There may
be a lot of other things you're doing already. The survey
results can be a point of communication and conversation. We hear
you. We hear you're concerned about this, and this is what our city's
doing. And that can really be kind of a magic moment where this you can
respond to the data. We provided flyers for
Okay, thank you. We appreciate your stuff, and, uh, we'll be able to
use that information to help make things better. Did you have anything else
to add, Abby? No, I think a lot of it
is really great though to use for planning and things like that, knowing that they
want more retail and more community events. I really like that, so I appreciate them
doing the survey for us. Thank you. Thanks, thanks for the opportunity to drive
down. Yep, appreciate it. The traffic's terrible leaving town,
so good luck. We'll get some snacks.
Yeah, so with that, we also had our community survey,
the annual community survey, and I think we're gonna
run right into that with Evan. Did you have— okay, yeah, go ahead.
Sorry. Go ahead. Didn't mean to interrupt you. Good afternoon, Mayor and Council.
I'm pleased to introduce Ron Gailey. He is from OnPoint Insights.
We have worked with their company a number of times before on previous surveys,
including our general plan survey, previous annual surveys.
Today he is here to talk with you all about our annual
survey. We do have a basic framework for that that
we like to use year after year so that we have comparative results over
time. But he is here because there is some wiggle room where
we can make sure that we're getting the answers to questions
that you have from our community at this point in time. So I'll
go ahead and let him take the floor.
Hello everyone, and I'm going to share my screen really
briefly with you.
Okay. On the annual survey, one of the benefits
of the survey that we do do is it allows you
to see, as we saw with the other one, what's important and how you're performing.
But we do it across a great many attributes.
This particular page is showing you from 2024 the
top 20 attributes of about 50 of
what people thought was most important. and then how you're
performing on it. And I only wanted to show you this just
to let you see where things were 2 years ago about what
is important and how you're performing. I've been working with Evan,
and we've been working together to make a
few minor tweaks to the main part of the survey. It's very
solid. I think it's very consistent with the past,
but some things I think are being strengthened. Thank you. or broken out when something
was important and we couldn't tell specifically what was inside.
We're doing that, I think, better for you this year.
We're reducing the number of questions about streets and
roads so that you don't,
like, double count and so forth, right? It'll be a little cleaner on
streets and roads. But then what
I wanted to ask you today As we're wrapping
up the survey and getting ready to go live, is if
there are additional topics you feel we really ought
to explore so that— we have
always in our survey about 3 minutes of questions that we
can go deeper on and ask some additional questions.
And I just wanted to talk with you about maybe some of the things that
may be of interest to you. In the past, we've done
questions about communications.
Now, you know, we had talked about doing more on
parks and recreation, but that's kind of— we held off on
that after my last presentation to you.
But just wanted to find out if there is something where you'd
like to go a little bit deeper this year and explore something that
might help you as you plan for your General plan, or as
you plan for your budgeting.
I would be curious to know, and I'm going to get the council's opinion on
this as well, but I'd be curious to know what would the what the residents
would feel and how and how they would rank like an ice skating
rink versus a field house versus other rec options,
and where they would want us to put our energy. It's a really smart way,
and oftentimes we'll give them a list of about five or six items and have
them prioritize them. I would love to see that. I would be really curious to
see that data. Is there a way when you ask that question
to help them understand the financial impact on them?
Because I think everybody wants something until they realize what the price tag is.
There is a way to do that. And it's
a smart thing to do. As a matter of fact, if you have narrowed it
down to 1 or 2 or 3 things maybe,
and we can put the financial implications of that, we can do
that. In some cities, we'll ask them something like,
if we were to do, let's say, a skating
rink. If we were to do a skating rink, should we go big,
go good, or go fair? You know, you do
that, and most people say go big or go fair.
Very few say go adequate. Then you say, well, go big means this
financially, probably, and go go good means
this, probably financially, and go fair means this.
What do you think now? And they'll tell you. And normally with that,
you can find out if you got a go for it or a don't go
for it kind of a response. We've done that for Maple— Mapleton.
We've done it for several cities, as a matter of fact. One of the
other things that has come up over the course of this year is trying
to better understand how our residents need
us to communicate with them, what mode of communication.
And I know that we're attempting to do quite a
bit of a spectrum of communication, but it would be great to get
a better handle on what people are hoping for. So whether that's
mailed postcards, emails, right,
you know, all the different things. We've done that for many cities that have a
great structure for And we can just make sure that it's dialed in for
your specific options here that are under consideration.
The other one that came up previously, and I still think I'm a strong
advocate for getting the answer for, is which recreation
programs our residents want to see us work on next.
'Cause we've got a little smattering of everything, and we've just
brought— we're bringing soccer in-house for this fall. But I would
like to know what's the next one we should be studying, where we should be
putting our efforts into. So— Do you know, I like that question.
It's a little bit long, you know, because there are several options.
And I would suggest that be added to another
survey. We— it
normally takes to do that question, it normally takes about 6 or 7 minutes
to kind of go through and find out, like,
For the different age groups, like which of these ideas for recreation
they would most like to do. We can potentially
shorten it and we can potentially make it fit, but that
one is a little bit more time-consuming to get it right.
I— do you think that we could gather adequate
data just to give us a general direction
in which to head? Because— Probably not all of them. Right. All of
these that you're talking about, like one— I mean, it's a little more— the communication
one, that's like 2 minutes. So that's OK. But this one's
probably about a 4 to 5 minute, even if we try to do it adequate.
Because I don't— well, of course, I don't know what all the programs are in
your facility. I think that's what I'm getting at is if it was just
our like first shot across the bow to figure out like which
direction we should at least start getting information, Doesn't have to be so extensive
in the very first thing? It doesn't. I can show you one we did.
So I can show you one and why what I'm envisioning takes more
time. I can show you one that we did for a city.
And we did one for Tremonton, Utah, but we did one for Melissa, Texas that
I'd like to show you. Both are good. And they each
took like 4 to 5 minutes to do well. But we could do
a shorter version, which I'm going to show you the Melissa, Texas one because it
is short, the one question, but it doesn't go into depth
into what goes within it. So I'm going to just open up my screen here.
Can I— I got one question on that screen real quick. Sorry. Uh-huh.
Just because I want to know the nature of the question.
We can wait. It was towards
the bottom. I can come back to it though.
Oh, hey, I'll come back to that. Okay, here you're
saying where we were, right? Okay, so right here,
uh, the question or the— sorry,
it's right there. It says, uh, city's own police force.
It had 9% as far as important,
uh, 7% were very good, but then the very poor was 67%.
What was the nature of that question? Does the 67 represent that
people don't like the Sheriff's Office or that they prefer
their own? You see what I'm saying? I think this question, you didn't have one,
right? And we put it in there, how is the city doing with the police
force? And I think it came off negative.
And, but we didn't explain
it or go into detail of what that would involve or what was, you know,
or how it is. I think this is just a general
rating of the police force at the time. So is it fair to say that
that's really not a very good representation of what's
really— because of the nature of the question? I think it is, because, yeah,
I think in general we're just asking them to rate the police force.
I don't know if they're rating traffic. I don't know if they're rating patrolling
the neighborhoods. There are a lot of things we don't know about that particular
question because we didn't go into depth. I think the word own
is what's throwing me off. That's why I'm— that's where I
was at too. Right? That's a nuanced word to throw in there. So that's why
when you say own, then what's the results? And then if it's not
important, meaning 9%, but yet it's 67% poor.
Well, then also because if we go to the police department,
which we did rate, right? And you see the 5th one
down? a fair number of people have had interaction
with the police, and if they did, the results are pretty solid.
Yeah, and that's why I said the nature of the question. And maybe
the answer, because I have to agree, that one was like, they're not rating
something that you have, they're rating something that you don't have. I think it's the
nuance between whether we have our own police force or whether we have a sheriff's
contract. Right, it should have been a separate question. That's where it gets skewed.
Could we just talk about maybe police presence instead
of calling it police? I think, I think that's fair, and,
and I do think that is a fair question and an excellent one, Mayor,
to bring up. And I think the, the follow-up
question after that would be like, do you feel safe?
Like, because I think those are like, do you see our police here
and do you feel safe? Those are like, I think— In most cities, that's the
way we have done it, is where you just talk about Neighborhood
patrols, and you find out that, and then overall, how are they doing?
But so I don't see that you have a police problem, and maybe
they don't like the idea of making your own. But 2% of our people
love the court we have.
But I would say that this was not the perfect question,
Mayor. Now I am going to
go to Melissa, Texas, and show you one question. So the question So
the way we did this is we said—
here it is. As the city begins to budget for the
next fiscal year, the city needs input on what recreational
classes, events, and programs are of most interest for our residents.
Our city may or may not be able to meet everyone's wants or desires,
but it's helpful to know what's valuable. And then we showed
them the list that you see here, which is rather broad.
So there's fitness programs, sports programs,
outdoor nature programs. They just had a variety. They had so many things
they were considering doing. They had about 60 or so ideas
of things that they could do. And this gave them a broad overview
of the types of things that came out highest. Is that
the direction you're thinking? I think for us, I mean,
for me, when I ask, We just barely brought soccer in-house,
and outside of junior jazz, there's not a lot of other things that
we are providing. We partner with outside organizations to
bring those services here. I would like to know which sports
type thing is the next specific thing recreation-wise
that they want us to do, because we have lots of really great opportunities
within our community from private entities for fitness and
and some of those other things. At least there's something, but there's not private entities
per se that are offering really good versions of recreational sports.
So for me, it's more of a, which is the next sports thing you
want us to take on? So when we did it
for this city, after we asked about a lot of attributes,
it narrowed down to these are the top 20 that people were most
interested in seeing. And I don't know if you can see this well, but they
just had a variety of things that they would love the city to focus on.
But this did allow them to focus on the few that
they wanted. And maybe we show you this list and you choose from
the list of what we were considering in another city, and we narrow
it down and have a smaller list that would be in your consideration set here.
And then we just present the things that you're considering.
Okay. Anything else on that one? Was that the end of the results?
I want to make sure. Is there more slides? No more slides that we need
to show. And really, we were just trying to
get feedback for anything new that you wanted. And this was super helpful.
And a thing to clean up. Which I think is also helpful too. So we'll
do that with the police. When you say own the police, I mean, that's obviously
a nuance that could, for people who know, you know,
throw the question a different direction. I think it should have been a question of
its own. Should we own our own police, yes or no, or something like that?
But it shouldn't have been the rating in general.
Yeah. The rec stuff, and you added something,
right? You happy with the way it looks?
We did rec communications and then we just said major investments
into something like ice skating. Yeah, the nature of communications, that's a big problem we've
had and maybe we talk about the way that question is worded, but it's—
the public has had a big push this year
about transparency. It's not a matter of being transparent, it's a matter of— Getting the
information out. Yeah, even if we said it, they didn't hear it or didn't get
to them. We need to figure out a way to
better get the word out to people
so that they have it available and in front of them. So that's
something. Did you want to add one more thing, Melissa?
Yeah. Oh gosh, I completely— oh, I was wondering if it would be instructive,
because I think we've had 3 different iterations of our Citizens
Academy. What if there was just one question with the demographic
stuff was like, have you participated in the Eagle Mountain Citizens Academy?
Because I think those people tend to have a better understanding of
what's going on and make very informed decisions. And I think it'd be kind of
fun to see, are they a statistical outlier or like that?
So it's almost a demographic, right? That's what I'm getting at. A demographic
of the handful. How many have been through it?
Probably 60.
Yeah, because it's 60 people. Do you know what? I just don't think it makes
sense to use that as a demographic. If you— I mean, you have what,
60,000 people here? We're going to go to 1,000 people. 80,000.
Oh my heavens. And then we're hoping to find those 60 people out of the
group, and it's probably very unlikely we would get 5.
Okay. A lot of the people that have been end up coming to the meetings.
Yeah, for sure. Look, I'm in favor, but— and you may want to
find out people who'd be interested in going through as the Citizen Academy. We could
ask people if they'd like to do that. And then you could just, you know,
you could get a nice list of, you know, if so,
you know, give us your contact information and you could invite people who are
very interested in that. You guys, do we want to know— I
know we talked about recreation and communication. Do we want to talk about
what resources we as a city or private
entities have brought into our community? Like, The fact that Department of Workforce
Services is coming, food pantries, some of those things like are—
because we always kind of guess and throw a
dart at the dartboard when it comes to Community Development Block Grant funds,
and I'm just wondering if that would be a useful question.
What's the question? Whether or not— which services
our residents want us to be providing. Post office. Well, yeah.
Yeah. I got that question today. Bus routes. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. All right. So we already know that.
Yeah, I think it's a little bit too broad. It would just have to be,
is there something missing? And then we just have to take the feedback.
Right. Right. Any other comments?
Off topic, I was gonna say that I did watch some of the podcasts.
Evan did great. Oh my heavens, yeah. Your team was
good in it. And then I watched some from like Colorado and some of your
other stuff. It was pretty fun. Do you know what? It was really something to
see all of the— that was a big topic and it's
getting bigger all the time. Yep, it was fun. So good job. Appreciate your team
and what they do for us. Thank you. Good, thank you.
All right, we're gonna move on back to the top. Item 1A, the Eagle
Square commercial signs. And Steven is up front
today with that one.
All right. Thank you. Lacey, can I have the screen, please?
Sorry. As it's coming up, so as an
introduction, as you know, the Seagull Square
commercial, I don't know if the last time it's come to City Council when it
was approved, it's probably been a year or more. It's been platted.
If you've driven past it, they've been grading the site, working on it.
We have received an application to put 2 signs up
for the development. So one of them would be here on their— I
guess it'd be in the lot, but along that private road. There's no really
issues with that one. The one that's coming before you that we want direction on
is the one here along Pony Express. So it's the sign S1.
And the reason mostly to get
feedback is, is it is in the city's right-of-way.
So typically that's— we don't allow any structures in the city's
property, especially in the right-of-way. Yes,
there's potentially to allow it if that's the city council's desire,
whether that's through a lease or how that you want to figure that out.
But before we move this sign application forward, we just want that direction and direction
for the applicant how they should proceed.
Yeah, I think if there's no utilities or issues there, I mean,
it, it doesn't look like it's in the way as
long as it's not blocking visual traffic or creating any
safety issues. Do you have any concerns with safety? If we were to widen
the road down the road, um, do we have
an idea of what kind of cost we would be saddling
a future council and taxpayers with? Would it just be essentially
building a new one?
Well, that's a risk for them, right? But I don't think the city would be
bearing the cost of moving that sign. If we widen the road and we take
out their sign because we— sorry, it wasn't— um,
if we widen the road and it's our
project and we remove their sign because we're going to
put road there, don't we have an obligation to relocate that sign?
Typically, no. Like, in the case of a, you know,
using a good example would be a franchise agreement with a telecom or
cable company. We may, if it's for a city project, we make them move their
stuff at their expense. I don't know why we would treat this any differently than
Comcast or DirectCom.
Does it— can it produce any issues in the PUE?
That's one of the things I'm worried about is you have
other infrastructure that may need to go in there.
It's just one of the concerns that I have. If you want to run some
power or some water or some other supply down the side of the road,
what do we do in that instance? I will say that there's
already some city signs that are along that
area that have advertisements on them. And I felt like the
contractor that was putting it in was able to navigate bringing
the utilities and things that they needed to underneath and around the signs
as they are there right now. So I think it's probably
doable, but maybe engineering would have a better idea for us.
Yeah, Vince, I've heard a few questions— site triangles, things like that. I know David's
not here for the specific stuff, and then the utilities. You want to weigh in
Before we go. Yeah, we, we did take a
look at this and we, we worked with the applicant to make sure that this
sign was pushed back far enough so that even with future expansion of this
roadway, it wouldn't have to be moved again. We didn't want
to put it in a place where it works now and didn't work for the
future. And so yeah, we did look at that. We did have them push it
back a little bit so it's outside of that future right-of-way.
So as far as sight triangles, yeah, it's far enough back that it won't affect
the sight triangle coming out of that intersection. Even with expansion?
Even with expansion. Do we have any examples of where we have signage
right now that's in the current right-of-way that we should— that we could be aware
of that would look like this or that might be impacted like this?
It's my understanding that every
sign— so
here on the intersection of Ranches and Pony, um, there's a sign
here for this office building.
The Chevron has a sign. Um, both of those are
within the right-of-way as well. So there is some,
at least some historical context that we have done this
in the past for some of the businesses, recognizing that it's a risk for the
business and that at some point when that road— not if that road
widens, when that road widens. And I mean, we're seeking funding for that now.
So my hope is, is that we're tearing this sign down in the next year
or 2. I, for your sake,
Mr. Simpson, I hope that's not the case, but, but I
just think that's a risk that the development or developer has to be willing to
take if we're, if we're willing to say, go ahead and build it in the
right-of-way, recognizing that there's a risk it may need to come down.
Isn't this what David's working on with you, Mayor, at MAG, to try and get
the 7 lanes? Yeah, and I was just, I was kind of going to go
into that. I was with MAG today most of the morning, and, uh,
so as far as the TIP funds We were working on the RTP today,
but TIP funding we just finished,
and then the next one will be 2 years, and of course 3 years after
that before we get it. So it would be 5 years before we get it.
Now, would we pre-fund that? Likely.
But at minimum, it's not approved yet, but it would be.
So not in the next— it would be approved in 2 years,
then we'll Maybe
3. Yeah, so we'd build it in 3 to 4.
But that's the risk. And happy to allow the applicant to weigh
in as well if there was any other questions too.
Is there questions for the applicant?
I do. So, I mean, so Mr. Simpson, obviously you're making the request, so this
must be at least something that you're willing to, to,
to take that risk Yes. Yeah,
Councilman Wright, you're correct on that. We had worked with the engineering
department there, and the
recommendation for the future widening of Pony was
to go back 25 feet from top back of curb.
And so this sign begins 30 feet from top back
of curb, and then to clear the safety
issues, We're 80 feet from Porter's
Crossing, so we go east 80 feet to make sure those sight angles
are there. And so we're trying to make it
similar to our sister development to the west,
Porter's Crossing, where Ridley's is. That particular sign is entirely
in the city easement, and so when you widen that street,
we'll— we're going to have to move that sign. back.
That one's entirely there, done back I think in 2013.
That's exactly— yeah, we appreciate the consideration and,
uh, to let us put this one, uh, in, in the
right-of-way following the recommendations from the city engineer
and the planners.
So anybody going to struggle with that?
No, it sounds like staff worked with the applicant to really get it where
it needs to be, so I don't have any objections. So probably the direction,
Mayor, is to just bring it back and let us do it, let us deal
with it as an action item, right? Okay.
Okay. Is that fair enough?
Sounds good. So do you want the agreement drawn up then and brought back to
you? Yeah, and I think the direction is obviously the owner's risk,
right? That would be the key factor. Other than that,
I didn't hear any other major concerns, right?
So if you're okay with that, then I think that's what we'll
do. Okay, perfect. Okay, any other comments or questions?
No, just that I need an encroachment letter from Vince
for the sign too. That's a public utility easement.
It's not in the city right-of-way, but it is a PUE. And so I have
my encroachment letters from all the other utilities,
but Eagle Mountain needs to provide one. So yeah,
for us to If that gets drafted, either one. And Vince has got
an email on that. Drafted and reviewed by Marcus, and then, uh,
then we can do it as an action item to approve the,
the contract, if you will. Okay. The letter, however Marcus
directs us. So is that all right?
Thank you. Okay. Yep. Thank you. And Stephen will help that process move along,
so. All right. Moving right
along. I appreciate everybody being ready today. So, 1B,
the home business standards. And I think this
one's Brandon.
I put it on the agenda, but this is just— I
put this on here for the council to have a discussion about the
home business standards. You know, they're in Title 17.
Chapter 65. I think there was some question
about whether the council should— I think
they just want to— the idea is to have a discussion about whether some of
the home business requirements should be adjusted to allow—
I know one type of use was maybe for agriculture or farm-related
uses. So I think Councilor Clark has a little bit more
information. For you, I do. I've had at least four different
residents reach out to me as a council member to talk to me about some
of this. There are some that have open application with
business licensing, and our home business license,
the way it's set up right now, is the only thing this particular business
can get licensed as is like a greenhouse home-based
business. And based off of what I've
heard and read. That our city attorney has said is if it's,
um, a greenhouse one, then the only thing that they can sell is
greenhouse products, which they deemed was plant starts,
microgreens, plants, and potentially even broadening
it wide enough to include bees and bee-related items,
right? Um, but one of the things that they
would like to do is to sell more than just produce and plants,
but to be able to sell like eggs from their chicken coop and
other farm-related items. So I think that this code
could be updated as simply as changing it
from greenhouse products to farm products and then provide some
definition of that. Um,
if we did that and they just complied with the rest of the home business
licensing requirements like trip count and some of those other things That
I think would take care of it. Steven, I know that you've—
did you talk to the applicant at all that had the open application?
Have they reached out to you specifically, or they've just been working with Jonna?
I've talked to them. Okay. Is there anything specifically about, or?
I'm just wondering if there's anything else that we need to
discuss as a body to determine whether or not we want to make this change.
Change. So it broadens it to kind of support those
agricultural uses. Yeah, I mean,
I think, like Councilmember Clark mentioned, I don't think our code meets what she needs
to do now. Um, opening up to whether
it's animal products, animal byproducts, that, that's,
yeah, a different conversation. That would probably encompass more of what she's looking for.
Um, honey was one that Our code doesn't explicitly allow right
now to be able to sell out of the house. So it's
really— we could go a lot of different places, but for this one specifically,
that would help. One other thing, just to piggyback— sorry,
Councilmember Whiting, I jumped the gun on you. Um,
baked products is also something that we're seeing a lot and lot— a lot
more of our residents doing, and they'll advertise it and say, I've made 8
loaves of sourdough, you can come pay for them and Venmo me and pick them
up on my porch. They're just front porch bakeries in effect,
and they're not getting tons and tons of traffic, but it
is a way for our residents to be able to stretch their income
and, and support themselves a little bit more and be a little bit more self-sufficient.
So that's one other item that kind of came up in that discussion. I was
just going to say I 100% support this. This is,
this is to me part of the culture of Eagle Mountain, and we need to
have this.
I don't disagree with that, Councilmember Whiting, but I guess I do
have some concerns. Is there a line that
needs to be drawn? That's really the question that I'm asking, because are we
going to allow the slaughter of cows and the resale of beef?
I just think that this is something that probably requires a little more forethought
and some discussion. What about chickens? You know,
Do you want to buy some chicken breasts from me? Because I might raise some
chickens and bring them, make them available for purchase.
So I just think that those are some of the discussions that perhaps we should
have. I think we should look at loosening it up a little bit. I'm not
arguing a counterpoint. I just think that, I think there has to
be some guidelines and some boundaries that we set.
I think To Councilmember Wright's point, there are quite
a few regulations, both federal, state, county health department,
that would govern some of those additional things. But things that
are like, uh, the bread, the eggs, the honey,
right now our code— Milk. Milk, uh, milk is governed by a
state code with raw milk stuff, and so is meat, to be honest with you.
Um, and that has to be done at like a USDA butcher, all of those
things. But I think, um,
we could broaden it to farm products and then
dig into some of the concerns, um,
concern areas that you're talking about. Because I do know that there are
people within our community that do sell meat that
they've raised, but they bring the meat, the animal, to a butcher,
then bring the butchered meat home and sell it for
pickup and different things for people to purchase. So I think in
a lot of ways it's already happening. But in
this particular instance, they went through the motions of getting a
business license and it helped us discover a
hole in our business license code.
I think to me the scope probably needs to be
narrow, one by one, not a categorically hear all the
things so we can have more thoughtful discussion around eggs, how many eggs,
and what falls within this, within the state code.
I know there are businesses that are operating outside
of our code today, like RV parking is a big one, that we should
probably have a bigger conversation about that as well.
But yeah, I don't, I don't have an issue, but I think we probably want
to keep the scope narrow and within the confines of the state law and federal
law. Do you think that our restrictions of how many trips
per day, how many employees they can have on site for a home-based business,
are restricting enough, narrowing enough
to be able to get it to where it needs to be instead of deciding
how many eggs or how much meat or some of those other things? Because I
think the trips is a natural limitation that's built
into our code already. Yeah.
So, well, and I think, uh, off-street parking has to
be part of that so they're not plugging up streets. Trips per days, uh,
if those things are all addressed in the home-based business already,
that's a start, right? So is that the main concerns?
Not so much what's for sale, it's, uh,
more about trips, parking, Any other major— I
think the goal is to have some kind of— if you want to start a
business, you're likely going to do it out of your garage. That's the whole point.
But it gets to a point where you need to go buy land and
go big. And it's figuring out what's that transition from being
a home-based business to taking advantage of the
residential discount on your property tax. What I'm wondering— so I was thinking
about this a minute ago, but You reminded me, like, say you're going to sell
meat or slaughter chickens, right? Something that we just got brought
up. Do we do that on a quarter-acre lot, or does it have to meet
the animal code table, if you
will? You know, you can't have beef until you have— is it half acre
or 1 acre, depending on what the—
Does the beef have to be raised on your lot, or could
you have an ag lot somewhere else that you're raising ranching the beef on
and then butchering it. Well, that's, that's what I was thinking through.
Can you tie it to that table to avoid— I mean, if you're
on a 5th of an acre and you're selling, commercially selling beef
that is generating 25 trips, you're also turning your place
into a refrigerated— your house just became a meat locker,
right? You couldn't do it on a lot that small, so you're going to need
a storage shed or something outside of that. That's kind of why I thought Can
you correlate it with the lot size in the animal code? It doesn't necessarily have
to be raised there, but to sell slaughtered chickens and beef,
you know, maybe you need more room. I think the home-based business
code does set some guidelines and it sets some guardrails
there, you know, with the trips per day, the number
of employees. And I think it's really just differentiating
between a commercial business and a home-based business.
And, and if we can do that, I don't think we should be regulating
things so that somebody that wants to keep bees can't sell the honey.
That's ridiculous to me. And if our code doesn't
allow for that, we need to fix it. And I think that's what Melissa is
talking about. But by the same token,
I don't think that we should be creating commercial chicken
egg production farms in our Townhome condominiums,
right? I just— so I think that we have to just balance it. And I
do think that the animal code will play a big part in that. And I
think the home-based business already does some of that.
Yeah, that's where I was saying, if you can get the home-based business, the animal
code to kind of dictate some of the uses or something. So then
if that's going to come back, obviously, Brandon, you'll assign that to
whoever's going to work on that code. Do you feel like there's
Clear direction on the guardrails. Yeah, I think we've got enough
information. Yep, sorry, thank you. I think we have enough information to move
forward on this one. Is there anything else that we need to
do? Okay, I think that's perfect. We appreciate that.
Was that good? All right, um, all right,
item 1C. I think this is our last of our discussion items. This is
the community garden presentation. I know there's a slew of people here that
are going to work on this, but Steve, did you have an introduction or do
you want to turn it over to the community board?
The Community Services Board has been discussing this, and especially
at their last meeting, and we invited Jen Corrington
from, from the community who's heavily
involved and puts together the farmers market.
Yeah, and I know Brad's also had some, uh,
insight here, so go ahead.
Hello, Mayor and Council. Oh no, it's not going.
Okay, so I am here to present a
community garden pilot program.
What we're— all we're asking for tonight is if you support the idea
of it, if the site that we have proposed is acceptable,
and if we should keep going forward with the idea.
The reason we want to do a community garden or have this is because there's
a lot of residents without yard space. And it
would be a way to learn and teach skills
of self-reliance and create community connection, and it could
be scalable if it— if this one works.
This is the proposed site, so it's over not far from here, just west
of Pioneer Park. West? Yeah.
And this is close up. This is what it looks like. I'm not sure exactly
where in this Rectangle, it would be, but it's somewhere
in this rectangle. And that's my understanding of
it, at least. We would just need to have that confirmed. How it
would work is we'd have five to ten raised beds approximately,
and we would need they would have improved soil and drip irrigation.
We would have a coordinator, which is why we've invited Jen here,
which she has a lot of. Experience and expertise,
and she would be able to run the program for us. And ideally, we would
have zero requirements from the city.
We wouldn't need any hours from you guys,
except for maybe a few confirmation things and things we can't
get around. The idea—
this is a model that we looked at— was the Wasatch Community
Gardens, which They have assigned plots to each to specific
residents, and they have an each bed has a named steward.
They have a remedy period, so if someone stops maintaining their plot, they have to
fix it within a certain amount of time, and then they
have a requirement for volunteer hours for the gardener.
We what we had talked about was having a small,
modest annual plot fee and a minimal monthly maintenance fee that could
go towards things like, um, what did we
say? Seeds. Oh, seeds and the, the water and fertilizer
and things like that. Um, and then we'd have raised beds with imported soil,
which avoids— I mean, we have rough soil
here. It's hard, can be hard to grow things. So we would have some soil
brought in, and then we would just have oversight by a
subcommittee on the Community Services Board, and then that
would be— that subcommittee would be mostly manned
by someone like Jen if that were to be who was voted in.
Having a drip line makes it so
that we wouldn't be wasting any water. The water's already there,
and we wouldn't need to have any— I
mean, we would still need to have a hose With a little bit, we'd have
to have water to be able to put in the new plants, but it would
all be maintained by a drip line.
And then this was just potential, a range of costs
of what it might cost to start up. There are things that we have added
in later phases, like having a fence and a shed,
that could be done sooner or later, depending on what you guys thought about.
And then the
timeline would— we would just need your direction now, and then in
the fall is when we would like to prepare the site and have it all
ready to go by spring.
And so that's what we would need. And do you guys have any questions?
So that's where the disc golf course is, right? And so
how And so I
guess one of the questions you had is, is this going to take what
could have otherwise been parking? Yes, that is one of the things on there.
Some people had requested— they
had made a request saying that they would like parking there, and that would be
a good spot for it.
But there is a water line there today. Yes. In that parking area?
Mm-hmm. So we've got irrigation running through there, is that right?
Yeah, as we mentioned earlier, I think in a previous meeting when we
discussed this, there is a meter that's already been set there with a
backflow prevention device. In the past, we have
had community gardens tried to be facilitated there twice
that I know of, and we did the same thing. Where the city basically
covered the cost of the seed and most of it was native
type vegetation that
would be grown and edible. And so, but we
just never could get it to take off. And I think the city ended up
spending about $10,000 through about 2 efforts and we never seen a byproduct
from it. So that's the history of it. But as Jessie
reached out, my conversation with her was, If we're gonna go back and we're
gonna pilot a site, I think that we should try the same location and
just see if we can figure out and get something moving, and then you
can figure out how to modify from that point. And so that
was my recommendation.
And that way we're not losing as much if it does for some reason fail.
But as us and the Community Services Board, as we discussed
with Jen, I think that having her as
the coordinator for this will make it a win.
Yes, you can make a comment.
Thanks so much. Um, I— we've had a lot of people reach out from the
community that are very, very interested in doing this. We had one guy that came
and talked for about 45 minutes to us at the farmer's market about it,
really interested. Older retired people sometimes, and there's so many
people who want to know how to garden. but don't know how.
And especially with our economy, I think that it is an important thing
that we try and feed our community. So even
though I would be over it, I would recruit
other people. And I think that is going to make the difference of whether it
succeeds or fails, is if we have people who are really interested in
doing it, who have the time, who want to donate that, and actually
make it happen. And I think it also needs to be food plants,
things that they will actually eat, rather than just something
that is native that's edible. I think if we're, you know, and if
we do it right, the right way, I think that it could be really successful.
And it could— we could possibly have several of these throughout the community.
So the people that are being drawn in into the Can
they be from anywhere in the city, or is this going to be like a
zone restricted only within a certain area? I think—
Do you just go out and sign up for it and go farm? I think
anybody in the city. I don't think it necessarily has to be from that neighborhood.
And then if it turns out good, then we— okay, we put it into another
neighborhood. So part
of what— just to clarify what Brad was talking about too with the physical
Financial impact and things like that. My understanding is at this point, very little to
zero staff time and no financial ask from
the community. At this time, that is correct, yes. We're just looking
for direction. Won't it need some to install water,
like to get the spigot part of the water line on and some
of those other things staff-wise? So it's just setup
cost but not maintenance costs, correct?
Yes. Okay. I actually am a huge supporter of
this. There's places all over the state of Utah where Master
Gardeners go and volunteer to Thanksgiving Point, Temple Square.
They go and they help maintain a certain area that they're given
responsibility for, and it's awesome. So like, I think this is the direction we
want to head as a city. Well, and on
this, like, something that I know has been thrown around out there is different
classes, and what better place to have a gardening class and add a garden.
It would give us a place to do that.
Mayor? I just want to add one. I think my biggest
concern with this idea over the years has just been the liability that it
could potentially put the city into. And what I mean by that is we've talked
a lot about in these corridors putting a lot of fruit trees in or
doing these community gardens. And what if somebody goes out
and sprays chemical application on something to treat for some bug
that's there and then somebody picks the fruit and gets sick.
And so that's my protective nature of the city to
bring up these things. And I think that some of those things need to be
mitigated as we work through this. And I think that we need some barriers
or parameters to work through it and address some
of those situations if we are gonna move forward with it, just to protect the
city. Like a waiver, I understand that I could die from eating
these peaches. I also think that the fence probably
is, one that should happen sooner rather than
later because— and we get a lock on the water spigot.
And those— somebody asked the cost of the water.
That is part of what that monthly maintenance fee for whoever
is. They would basically rent a space. Like, say for instance, the box is a
4 by 8. They would rent a 4 by 4 or a 4 by 8.
And so then those monthly costs would help pay for all of those
My only thought is if we move forward with this, and I'm
supportive as well, that we just have good materials,
that we don't halfway do this where your 2x4s are rotting out
in 2 years. I mean, I think this is a social
experiment. They don't own the boxes, they don't own the material,
the equipment. It's not their own property. And when it's not
yours, you tend to just let things dilapidate. I think that's a good point.
So I think if we move forward, that the
materials would need to be good quality, that can be durable,
last a long time, like a playground. You just build
it to last. Well, and I fully support that, and that can get a little
more costly, of course, but that is why, I mean, if the city was
open to it, we could have a sponsor-a-bed program or something like that where
different people or businesses could donate money or They
could donate the bud for us, and that would be
a way to make sure it was done the right way. See, and I like
that idea because it could help people that maybe couldn't afford to pay the maintenance
fee, but they could seek sponsorships. But so what I'm hearing, or what I'm understanding,
and maybe you can correct me, it sounds like there's support,
but we need maybe some— I don't
know if I want to call it a contract. We need some guardrails or some
agreements, if you will, LOI, whatever Mechanism that says
here's the the property, here's who the manager
is at this time, and and here's how it's going to operate. For instance,
the liability question on the sprays that if there's spray used
that number one has to be approved by the city first. You can't spray without,
and then secondly posting a sign or something that says
that this has been sprayed, or you know there's some kind of. Notice,
you know, I'm just giving an example. So go ahead. Yeah,
I'll share some thoughts. I'm probably gonna be the one who's the outsider on this
a little bit. I don't think this is a good idea for the city to
get involved in this. And so my
approach to it would be to look for corporate sponsorship, to find a way to
put it. I think the city could donate the land, or at least dedicate the
land and make the water accessible. But I don't think the city should take
responsibility of managing it, or playing any part of it.
I think if the community wants to see it be successful, that we should
go seek some private funding to put in the original beds,
and then let the city dedicate the space for that to happen, and let those
who wanna come participate pay the few dollars that you're talking
about to be able to do that. And Jen, I don't know where you're gonna
find your time. I mean, I know how busy you are. I'm grateful that you're
willing to teach that to our residents, and I think that it, I think
in concept I really enjoy it. I just don't think it's something the city should
be funding and being held responsible for.
So I think that is the thing, is it's on city land, and that's why
I wanted the guardrails. There is no funds asked and no staff time,
but the land is there. So like, that's why I said I think we need
the sign that says that, you know, it's been sprayed, or— But
who's going to take that, Mayor? I mean, and who's going to monitor it?
Are we going to have a staff member that goes by and watches this every—
I mean, those are the problems that I think these types of things cause,
or at least the concerns from a liability standpoint.
I mean, if I'm a private business owner and you're asking to come do this
on my property, I have all the same concerns that I have as a member
of the city council for the city. I mean, there'd have to be some indemnification
from my perspective of anybody who participates in it or consumes
anything that's grown in it. The city needs some indemnification from
my perspective. There's just too many unknowns in
that. That's problematic for me as someone who looks out for
some of those things in my own private life, in my own business.
The buck always stops with me. If you can find someone to
sponsor, I'll sponsor a bed. I'll just say that out loud and on
the public record. I'll be happy to sponsor a bed at the $200 or whatever
you need, but I think we We can find a way to do that through
our business partners rather than trying to
put that on the city. And only if we can find a path forward with
our attorney to find some way to indemnify the city against some
potential future loss. I would just kind
of ask too, with the concerns about liability, we have park
equipment that people play on and could get hurt at. How do
we indemnify ourselves with that? There's signage,
play at your own risk, those kinds of things. So I feel like
the way that we create some of the guardrails that
you're talking about, because us doing it as a city versus a private business
doing it, there's a lot different liabilities that you have
to take on as a business because the buck stops with you.
But as a city, it's to me it's like. Playground equipment in
a lot of ways. So I just maybe wanted to jump in there really
quickly. Um, as far as things like park equipment and all that kind
of thing, anybody can sue anybody for any reason, and the city could be sued
at any time. And that's why we have insurance with the trust. We mitigate the
impact of that by having policies and procedures in place, by having good
record keeping that says this is how we're maintaining this, and all that type of
I think what I'm hearing from various groups, there are various
members of the council here, is that the word guardrails
or the world or the rules or how it's going to be
administered— did the city act prudently? Did we put the right
rules in place? Did they sign the right waiver? Have we worded it properly?
Or whatever we needed to do to make sure that we mitigate
the risk if we do move forward with this in this direction. I have seen
this. I have seen it be successful in cities where there are participants
where that really come out. I've seen it die on the vine
more than I've seen it be successful when all of the work falls on one
person. And that's the big fear.
And so it's really when a collective group comes together and you have
a large enough population base that it's being watched, because oftentimes
if it is just a small group. Then you get the vandalism and you get
people coming in. And, and, and then I,
I have 8 kids and we've grown a lot of gardens and
we're really good at putting it in and really bad about, uh,
weeding and maintaining it. And it, by fall, it looks a lot different
than it did in the spring. So. I,
I just want to say that I'm super supportive of this because I think for
years I've been advocating for something like this.
And there's always going to be concerns about anything we
do as a city, but sometimes we need to say,
what is it going to take for us to get to yes? And I think
when residents bring something to us and say, this is what we want,
especially when we're looking at all of the tax things, our budget,
all of that stuff, this is a low-cost way to
say to the residents, We're still trying. We're being penny
pinchers about it, but we're still trying to make sure that you have those quality
of life amenities. So like, I want to help find whatever
the rules are, whatever the signage has to be, so that we can make this
wildly successful. Because I love when people tell us you're not going
to be able to do this. It's my favorite. So— I mean, we have their
community garden boxes in the Section 8 housing.
I'm just curious how they're functioning because those exist and they're on private
ground, HOA ground. So I mean, I think
there are opportunities that exist, Councilmember Clark, and I'm not aware of them actually
functioning in any meaningful way today. Now they might be, I could
be wrong about that, but I know that we have approved in some
developments those things as an amenity, and I'd be curious to see how they're functioning,
if they're functioning at all. Okay,
on the north side of Silver Spur Way, it looks like the city owns either
side of that. And so there's like a gravel area on the northwest
side, looks like it's city-owned, so people could park there. And then the northeast side,
if ever we needed to create a parking for the— this
golf course, it looks like there's room there. So I'm not worried about the
parking aspect and the garden taking that up.
So again, I think the two things that I've heard is number
one, maybe we'd set some land aside. We don't want to touch it outside of
that, and I think that is what they're saying. But then number two is I
think there needs to be some kind of agreement, if you will,
that says how it's going to function.
That's that's what if there's is that what the
council would or wouldn't support? Or is there more or less than that? That's what
I'm trying to get to. Is that— I think the money
is not the issue. We can find sponsors.
I think it's the support piece and whether or not we want to throw
our weight behind it as a city and try it one more time.
And maybe the Community Services Board works with their garden
committee to bring us what those guidelines are to bring, because they
have rules that they want to keep too, because they're going to be putting their
time into it. So I think for me, the next step that I'd like to
see is bring us the next layer of it, and let's see if we
can address some of the concerns, kind of mitigate some of those. So that's,
that's what I was getting at, is it wasn't a money question. They're not asking
for any money. The next layer is some type of LOI,
contract, MOU that says the city
gives the land, this is the manager, and here's what we'll do to You
know, as far as signage, spray, permissions, is that, is that what
we're looking for? Yeah, I think so. And is that something you'd support, or— I
don't want to do it as an exercise. I think anytime someone in our community
stands up and says, I want to lead an initiative to better our community,
our park, or whatever, and no staff is required,
let's do it. I'm in support, but I also think we
need to Be careful around risk, liability, that kind of stuff, which Marcus
is a genius. He'll figure that out. I support
this a lot. I'm really grateful. Our community connection score was low. This will increase
our community connection. I'm willing to give it a try. Let's do it. So it
looks like we've at least got a majority to go to the next step with
the contract. Now, I don't know that that's a staff-driven— I'll take a little advice
from staff, but is that something that we could let the Community Services Board— I
also know that Charlotte's here that worked on this. Could we assign them
to bring us something, or do we want to— Marcus, you went to—
do we want to do that wording ourselves? Was it— is it something that— I
know we're busy. Could they bring us an MOU? How do you want to see
it? Okay,
so I want to make sure I understand where we're at at this point.
So where we would agree to let them sort of
use our land, lease it,
if you will, for a community garden, they would agree to—
so who is the they, I guess, is the real question. Who's the entity we'd
be allowing to come in and do it? So that's my first question.
I think the city's authorizing the land and whether the management's
under the— So is it going to be our community gardens or somebody else's
that they're using our land for? Because I thought that— That's
what the latter was, what we had settled on. But if it's going to be
our program, then,
then I think it's a very different proposition versus somebody else's program on our
land. Well, it's definitely a city-sponsored group that's bringing
this. So yeah, so is that— So if it's going to be our program,
then we would, you know, have people sign a waiver of liability for using
the program. I mean, obviously Yeah.
You know, posting of signs disclaiming liability is helpful, though not
necessarily dispositive on issues of liability.
You know, it's just a matter
of, well, how are we going to manage compliance with
the program? Who's going to do it? Make sure that people are signing the
waivers, because it's one thing to say we're going to require waivers, another thing to
follow up and make sure that everyone who's engaged, who's using the program, whether as
a garden or as a customer of somebody using, you know,
growing something there or whatever, whoever's consuming it is signing
a waiver. I mean, that does sound very, you know, but that would be the
way we'd handle it if it's going to be our program and we just have
to be willing to accept the risk. So what's the tool that we want to
use to govern this? Is it an MOU? Is it a— With whom? It would
be with our community So, I mean, the committee, we wouldn't enter
into— the Community Services Board is not a separate legal entity.
But I think it's— Apart from the city. It's just, so you can't enter an
agreement with yourself. Well, then I wanna make sure that we are able to
list the protocol of how it's managed. So we would adopt
the policy. So do you wanna say— And this is how we wanna manage it.
So I would leave that to the Community Services Board to prepare. So have them
bring that to the policy.
And then I'd be happy to review it if they want me to,
and— or if you want me to, and we'll go from there.
But we would want anyone using the program to sign a waiver
of liability, or anyone volunteering. So let me recap
this again, and then I'll make sure we sell this board. So they will bring
us a policy that says this is how it will function,
with this who manages, this who oversees. How will signage, things like that,
whatever we've talked about, we would enact
it as a policy and then that managing members or member
would report to— Yeah, so we could have whoever we want,
you know, managing the program, you know, from city staff
as well as, you know, any board members. I pick Brad.
He's decent. It's probably
Zach, but— And I would say that there's enough
out there, that there's policies already in place, Salt Lake City
specifically. Do you know of some that you can point them to? I can find
it, I can find them. So then if we adopt it as a policy,
is there still head nods, still support to— Yeah,
and I think the liability form's easy. We can get 1,000 parents
to sign the liability form for bounce houses. every year
at Pony Express Days. I'm not worried about 12 people doing gardens. So— Well,
they would need to do a contract anyway with whatever they're doing.
They would need to do a contract anyway with whatever they're doing, and part of
that contract could be a section about liability. Um,
the only thing I would caution on that is if you do charge residents for
that, we want to make sure that we follow all financial policies and the cash
collection. We budget the revenue, we budget the expenditures that we might have out of
it. I mean, is that what you guys would like us to do if we
went this route, to charge?
Okay, I think that's gonna have to be part of the policy,
is what the fee is, how that's handled, and how you collect sponsorships.
Yes, the first one's going to come from Councilmember Wright.
He'll vote no and then he'll write you a check. That's possible.
Perfect. But I think that's
part of it. So with that, I think we gotta keep moving. Do you
have clear— ask questions. Okay, so are we good then if we do
go forward in the Community Services Board and create a subcommittee and
at least bring you a policy before anything gets started to have for approval?
I think that's the case, yes. And make sure that the policy has
all the items that we listed, the financial aspect, the Signage, things like
that. Liability. The liability waiver. Compliance with existing financial policy.
Yeah, compliance with existing financial policy. So if you'll
sign that,
or if that means that it's just you, one of you two, but assign that
policy, writing the policy, if I
can think. Yes, okay. And then get it with Ben and
Marcus Then we'll, uh, I'll write that policy.
Yes. Okay, is that good? Thank you very much.
Okay, thank you. All right,
moving along. We good? I feel like I'm a little
out of sort. So, um, moving on to our agenda.
I know we'll get through this as quick as we can, which I think we
can, uh, to get to our closed session. Uh, I do know that we had
a really good time I shouldn't say good time, a really busy time
in New York. But is there any other, uh, Item 3, City Manager information
items? Sure, I'll just cover a few things really quick.
Um, I just— there's a lot of things that we should be thanking our staff
for at this period of time. Um, I know it's been a very difficult time
for our community, but the amount of work that has been involved in completing the
audit and completing the budget and, and even going through with the tax
increase and all of the, um, follow-up items from election to grandma requests and
all that. So I just want to extend appreciation. I know the council has wanted
a lot of information from staff, and they've been, uh, very buried with, with other
things, such as coming up with, um, all the information needed for our
sewer treatment bond and all the different work that has been going on in different
areas. And so we've tried to manage that and try to manage getting requests back.
And so we thank the community, and we Thank the council for your patience,
and I thank the staff for their efforts involved in that.
With that said, October kicks off the 2000
FY 2026 audit as well as the FY 27
budget. So here we are again, and look forward to
a happy new year. And with that said, there has been a
lot of information gathering and whatnot so that we can be well prepared
for our sewer treatment plant expansion. The mayor
mentioned that we went through a bond rating exercise
with S&P and Fitch to be able to share
the story of our community and do so in a way that will show
the opportunities and the good things happening and hopefully lower our interest rates,
which would save our residents millions of dollars over the life of that
bond. And so I can't extend enough appreciation to all
the staff that helped us prepare and those that had the honor of going and
sharing our story. I think it was a very successful event,
and it was an honor to be part of that group.
Also today, we took a tour of Williams that's doing the
construction of the power plant down— facility down
south of Meta. That's a $1.7 billion investment
into our community, and it was exciting to take a tour and see all the
good things that are going on there. Thank you. They have 300 jobs in place
between now and 2028 while they're doing that work. And so
that's a significant increase in taxable value for our community that
will hit the books in 2028 and 2029. The construction will
be completed in '27 and '28, so that's why it's a year later.
And that's why some of the issues— we have some good things happening in our
future, but it doesn't hit the books until a little bit further out. And of
course, you need the power before you have the other benefits
from other development in the area. With that said, we have a number of projects
that are kicking off right now. Many of you have probably seen the Trailhead intersection
work start at the intersection of Trailhead and Pony Express where we
will have a new signal light. Campus Drive and Ranches Parkway will have
its improvements with a high-T intersection improved there.
The Scarlet Tank Ridge tank is moving Moving forward, about 10 months
left on that tank construction.
We've had a lot of improvements in work on wells of late.
I know Well 2 is up and running now. I know it had some issues,
but it is up and running. So we appreciate our staff being able to bring
that up and solve the issues that were related
to that maintenance issue. And Well 8 should be up and running in October.
Good things are happening there, and I think you can see it not only in,
in the community at large, but in our soccer fields. I think our soccer
fields are looking exceptionally good. I've had compliments coming in from the community
about those soccer fields and some of the improvements there, and I think we're all
seeing it in our yards with the blessing of the rain that we've had of
late too. So good things are happening in our community, and I just want
to extend appreciation to the council for all your continued support.
Yeah, and just, uh, when you're talking about the staff, also I'm gonna add our
consultants. Uh, Laura Lewis put a really good presentation together,
and then her staff, uh, I don't know them all, but that was
super successful. Um, any questions
on any of that? I know that was fast, just wanna make sure everybody's up
to speed. Okay, uh, let's go through the consent agenda real quick.
I, I think this is pretty easy. 10, uh, item 10A is the change
order, the White Hills 4 million gallon tank, and this
is the final kind of closeout. Were there any questions? I know
Vince is here to answer questions. Okay, anything that you need to add?
It doesn't sound okay. Item 11A: The minutes for our regular
city council meeting on August 18th and the August
26th special meeting. Okay, the preliminary plat
for Gateway Park Phase Three. I would like for us to pull that from
the. consent agenda so we can discuss that a little bit. There were some things
that came up during Planning Commission. This is for the charter school,
right? That I think would be useful for us
as a body just to quick talk about. So if you guys are willing.
OK, thank you. I agree with that. Nothing that we could solve now, right?
So it's just— OK, so we'll go ahead and pull that off and put it
on the regularly scheduled items.
A is a resolution of Eagle Mountain City approving the 2nd amendment to the Briley
Farms Phase B development agreement.
So did, did the applicant do what we asked
them to do? Yeah, they, they took it from the 40 with 600-foot garages
to the 20 that they've already built with 600-foot garages and
40 more that will have the 400 and— what is it,
490-something? And that was the size we were asking Well,
yes, that, that was what they demonstrated to us last time, so they actually
added an additional— what they did is we reduced it on 20 and they added
20 more. So I wanted to just thank you for that, for listening, and that
makes sense to me at this point. So we're comfortable leaving
that on the consent agenda. Thanks for coming. That was easy.
The 13B is resolution of Eagle Mountain City to become an official
member of the North Utah County Aquifer Council.
No questions yet?
No. And then 14A is ordinance of Eagle Mountain City amending
the Municipal Code 245.010,
the Youth Council term limits. And I wanted to make sure this— you
had a lot of— yeah, it looks good to me. It represented what you said
last night. That's great. Okay. And any other questions on
that one? 14B,
an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City amending the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code 3.30
regarding land disposals. This has to do with the map.
We don't have the map yet, but this has
to do with the state law changes. So we're updating our code to conform
to those changes. Okay, and no other questions on that one
that I can see? Okay, the rest are scheduled items.
I think because of what we have to discuss, unless there's specific questions
that need changes between now and then that we could hurry and go over— is
there anything that you know of that we need to, uh, to work
Yeah, you're good. There's nothing. Okay,
go ahead. Hey, Mayor, I move the council adjourn to a closed session
pursuant to Section 52-4- 205 subsection
1 of the Utah Code Annotated.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting, a second by Councilmember
Clark, and we'll start the vote with Councilmember Whiting. Yes. And Councilmember Hewish.
Yes. Councilmember Clark. Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes.
Okay, and that motion passes.
Yeah, and I was going to say that later, that Rich was missing,
but we'll get that in the policy session.
So You're
good. You're good. All right.
It's 7 o'clock. We're gonna get started.
Before we get started, I've asked Stephen to start us
Our Father in heaven, we're so very grateful for this
chance that we've been blessed with as citizens
of the city and staff members and those
that we come together to discuss those issues that are important to us
that affect all of our lives. We pray
that we may be cordial with one another, that we can be responsible and
thoughtful in our words and actions.
We ask that we may be guided in the
decisions that are made and the responses that we feel
are appropriate. We ask thee
as we end tonight that we all may
return back to our respective homes in safety and get
the rest that we need for the coming day. And these things we
pray for in the name of Jesus Christ, amen. Amen.
All right, it is 7:02, and I'll officially
call this meeting adjourned. Meeting to order of the Eagle Mountain City Council on September
1st, 2026. And before we get started, Council Member Whiting's
going to lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance. Please rise, join with me.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it stands,
one nation under God, indivisible,
with liberty and justice for all.
Okay, first of all, before we get started, I just wanted to excuse Councilmember Wood.
He's got some personal issues that he's taking care of, so we'll
excuse him from tonight's meeting. If he gets a chance, he may join us online
if that happens. So, um,
First of all, Mr. Reeves,
is there any information items? We do have some. Thank you, Mayor.
First of all, we have the EM30, the Eagle Mountain 30-Year Anniversary
Challenge that has kicked off today.
Stephen, do you want to talk about that? Steve?
Yeah, the EM30 Challenge is exciting. It's going
to be September through November. So it ends just before our actual 30th
anniversary on December 3rd. And it's a challenge
similar to the Walk 250 with America 250 that's to
inspire people to get outside, recreate, especially here in Eagle Mountain,
hike, bike, walk, run,
and then there's a bunch of other options if you're not able to
get out and do that, to read 30. So we call
it kind of Bike 30 or Hike 30 or Run 30 or Or read 30,
or sew 30, or serve 30, or do a lot of different things to celebrate
the 30th anniversary of the city. And then there's a
way to submit your completion of that
online, and you'll get an exclusive 30th
anniversary sticker and then be entered into a drawing for prizes.
Thank you. We also have, in conjunction with that, the America 250.
It's our 250th anniversary for our nation, and there's a
pop-up museum at the Cedar Valley High School on September
2nd, tomorrow, from 4 to 8 PM. Of course, a reminder
that our farmers market is every Saturday, 9 AM to 1 PM through October 10th
at Corey Ride Park. Our Constitution boot
camp, Wednesday, September 9th, from 7 to 8 PM at Cedar
Valley High School. Stargazing, Wednesday, September 9th, from 8 to
9 PM at Walden Park. Utah's statewide
virtual job fair, Thursday, September 10th, from 10 AM to 1 PM
on jobs.utah.gov.
There is a walk to fight suicide Thursday, September 10th, at 6 PM
to 8 PM at Cedar Valley Football Field. There's a
scorpion hunt Friday, September 11th, 8:30 PM.
Meet at City Hall, Council Chambers. September 11th
Day of Service is going to actually— is on Friday, September 11th, including Hero Parade
at the elementary school and flag ceremony at Cedar
Valley High School. We have Shop Fest
Saturday, September 12th from 9 to 5 PM at Corey Wright Park.
Days of Service— this is in conjunction with the September
11th, but ours— our Days of Service were going to be held this year on
September 15th, Tuesday through Thursday,
September 17th. So we have many activities planned throughout our
community, and we invite the community to participate. Our fall
dumpsters will be here for cleanup Wednesday, September 16th through Wednesday, September 23rd
at Quarry Ride Park. And we have an exciting announcement:
Eagle Mountain's own Xavier Gozo, who came up
through Real Salt Lake organization, has signed a five-year deal with.
Crystal Palace FC, making him the first player from Utah to reach
the Premier League, arguably the top soccer league in the world.
So we want to congratulate him.
Yeah, that was fun. I saw the news when we were working on that
bond, and it was, it's kind of fun to see an Eagle Mountain native get
that recognition, make it in the pro sports.
Thank you, Ben. Our next item, 8, this is the time set aside for public
comment. As a reminder, public comment is an opportunity
for community members to address the City Council, and each speaker is
allowed up to 3 minutes. If you wish to speak during the public comment,
the public hearing portion, please complete a comment form located in
the back and return it to our recorder on this side, and we
will recognize you during the public comment or during the public hearing portion.
Council members will listen but not engage in discussions during public
comment. We ask that everyone remain respectful. Disrespect— disruptive
behavior including cheering, booing, clapping, comments directed at
individual city employees is not prohibited— is not allowed— is
prohibited. If you have issues or
questions regarding staff or personnel, administrative staff will meet you in the foyer
for further discussion. So let us know if that's a case, and our
assistant Steve will meet you out in the foyer.
Lastly, public comment period is for items not associated with this public— the
scheduled public hearing. If your comment relates to public hearing
item, please wait till that item is called. Tonight's public hearings are 15A,
that's the code to repeal and replace the Section 1760 regarding
retaining wall construction, and 15B,
which is the ordinance rezoning
lands, certain lands known as Pinnacles, and approving the Pinnacles Master Development Plan
and Master Development Agreement. So at 7:08,
I will open the public hearing or the public comment period.
And— Yeah, we have Jason Ayu.
Jason Ayu.
You're good now. Okay. Good evening, Mayor,
Council. My name is Jason Ayew. My wife and I,
my wife Joanne and I, have been here for 26 years in Eagle Mountain.
This is our home, this is our community, and we're excited to be able
to discuss item 12A, which is a plat. And on that plat,
you're gonna hear about our site plan for a school that we propose.
It's a charter school called Ripple Academy.
Having my children have born and
raised here in Eagle Mountain and have been great products of the public school system.
One thing that I've learned from my own 2 children is that both, even though
living in the same home, they both have 2 completely different learning styles.
And my son Chaz thrived really well in a traditional
learning, moved on and went to college, graduated from college. My daughter
Zion, not so much. She really struggle with the traditional learning style. And so Ripple
Academy is a life-based learning model that,
you know, thinking about as we develop this school, it really would've been
fantastic for my daughter Zion to be in this school.
But we can't go backwards, we can only move forward.
And, you know, as we put some initial interest out there,
our school proposes hopefully will be open by next August 2027
if everything goes well, knock on wood. But we've already had over 300
members, 300 members of Eagle Mountain that have expressed interest into that
learning-based model of Ripple Academy. And so we just want to
put a name and a face in front of you as you— I'm
sure you'll hear from us many times forward, but thank you for your time and
hopefully we appreciate your support in getting our site plan approved. So thank
you. Anthony Wood.
How's it going? I put my comment down
under item 16, but it was— it's not really directed towards that.
Essentially, I wanted to say thank you guys. Thank you for, you know,
listening to us and working together with residents.
In regards to that truth in taxation, we did. I know you guys were
facing a lot of varying degrees of criticism, and much of
it seemed to be pretty distasteful. I know
you guys had a lot of late nights and very long conversations helping
everyone figure it out and get the information out there.
I appreciate we were able to come together and come to a very reasonable number.
I found myself talking to a lot of residents. Many of them
were blaming council members for all of the truth in taxation
stuff. And I found myself telling them a story and
that they needed to realize that they were slightly accountable as well.
Now, that story was essentially just imagine that your family
is the city. You know, you're the city council. Your spouse
is the mayor. Your kids are the residents.
You know, your family is pregnant, you have another kid on the way,
and you start saving up for a new car because you need one.
You know, after a few doctor visits, you find out you're having triplets, and now
that car is not going to do. You need a minivan. It's going to cost
a lot more money. You go to your family, you tell them like, hey,
I'm going to cut back on your allowances because we need to
finance this vehicle we can't quite afford, but we need it now.
No. You hear crickets. You come
back a couple days later, you tell them again. Again, no response. Crickets.
Now, what I was telling everyone is that, you know,
they get all mad when they find out that their allowances were cut.
You know, what are you doing? What are you doing? You know, you're cutting my
allowance back. You know, oh, we had to get that van. Well,
they'll start replying with like, we didn't need that van. Who told you we needed
that? Like, we don't need it. It's too expensive. where are you putting the money?
We could have done something different. You know, all those crickets during the first
conversations were us residents not coming to the first few meetings and
discussing everything and figuring it all out.
Ultimately, I was telling them that if you want
to know what's going on, or, you know, if you want to complain and have
some value behind it, you need to come to the meetings and listen and know
what's going on. I heard some residents talking about how 30
seconds remaining. Some residents were complaining
about like, oh, you know, we didn't discuss this. I want to know this,
I want to know this. And I was literally sending them dates of when we
were having council meetings in the past where you guys covered that. And I was
sending them video clips from those meetings.
And it's like, they discussed it, you weren't there. I just wanted to say thank
you though, so.
All right, that's everybody that's turned in a form. Is there anybody
that did not get an opportunity that would like to speak at this time?
Seeing no one, we will close the public comment
period at 7:13 and bring it back to the council. And,
uh, for this time has been set aside for them to make comments and
address the public. We'll start with Councilmember Clark.
Thank you, Mayor, and thank you for your thoughts.
Ironically, I have a set of twins, and we only
had one kid when we found out we were having them, and we
had to move to a minivan too, and it was a major life change.
It, like, we didn't fit in the car that we had anymore,
and it was a pretty big deal. So, like, I really
got the visual of what you shared. Thank you.
I have to remind myself when people get mad at me or
call me something on Facebook that the only difference between me and
the people who are saying what they're saying on Facebook is information.
And we're working hard to improve what we do as far
as information goes and getting that information out to you. And we're,
we're patient with our residents because we know what it feels like to
be angry about something or confused. Or afraid.
So give us, give us a little bit
of grace as we work through finding out information about how
to get you information. One of the things that we discussed during our work session
today was our normal community survey that we do each
year, and one of the questions that we talked about was finding
out from our residents what's the best way to communicate with you,
what mode of communication is going to actually serve
serve you the best. And I think that attention to detail is something that gets
missed by people who aren't here sitting
up on the dais. But we want you to know that we,
we really do want you to be a part of the process. We believe
in your ability to help us make decisions, and we're grateful that you're here.
And I just want to say too how grateful I am for our staff.
They put in countless hours. I know our recorder's office
had to get a packet ready, then they had to get a bunch of other
stuff ready and meet deadlines. And they're not the only
ones that are just busting their tails to make things go in our city.
And I just am super grateful. We wouldn't be able to be who we are
without you guys. So thank you.
Thank you, Mayor. Yeah, thank you, Mr. Wood. I appreciate your comments.
We've taken it on the chin for a few weeks, and it's nice to hear
somebody that actually appreciates what we do. Whether we get it right or wrong,
we know that we do both. I mean, I recognize
that, at least I get it that way. Sometimes I get it wrong,
and hopefully that's a minor amount of the time, and more
often than not, we make good decisions. I call them SUDs,
seemingly unimportant decisions, and we make Lots of them.
And I think that the more that we can make in a positive manner that
bring positive results, that ultimately those benefits and
blessings will come up and they show up on our doorstep. So seemingly
unimportant decisions that we make daily, weekly,
yearly as we sit here and have the opportunity to make those
decisions on your behalf. So thank you for your words.
Welcome to all of you that are here. It's good to see some smiling faces.
Mr. Ayoub, you don't know me, but I know your dad pretty well.
And what an awesome man your father is.
And so thank you for being— I didn't know that you're a member of our
community, so that makes me happy. I've only been here 22
years, not 26. So you got me beat there. And then
I want to just— I guess I want to make this point.
And I know that the council members know this. I met with the seniors today,
the senior citizens. I'm the liaison for the city with the senior citizens
from the city council, and they expressed some concerns and
some issues that they're having that are not unlike what our staff members deal with.
They need more room. They've got more members of their community
that want to come and they want to participate in their building. We added a
building there 2 years ago, 3 years ago. Was it last year?
Last year. It's— and they've outgrown it already. And it was just a trailer.
It's just a Connex. It's an extra, right? What do they call them
at the school? A pod of some portable of some sort. And we
were fortunate that we had some federal funds that allowed us to do that.
Didn't come out of our taxpayer dollars, at least locally. It came out of some
federal funds. And so I'm asking the council to consider perhaps directing
some of those CBDG funds in that direction towards them. But it
also underlines at least a major concern that I have is For our staff
members, we're looking at hiring some new people. For every
person we hire, we probably need 3 that we should be hiring.
And for every person that we hire, that's just,
that's just 10 more people that are having to work out of closets or from
home or remotely. And I don't think our citizens really see that impact,
but I'm, I've been here long enough now that I'm, I'm seeing that and we
just lose efficiencies when we have to function that way. So I hope that you'll
bear with us as we make many hard decisions. We're talking about a sewer treatment
plant, huge bond. But if you
want that stuff to go where it's supposed to do, we have to make the
right decisions, right? So I just, I want to express my love
and my gratitude to each of you for allowing
me the opportunity to serve. I'm nothing
special. I don't know a whole lot, and I've learned even
more having out here, but what I can promise you
is that every decision that I make, I will always do it—
I will always make it asking this question: What's in the best interest
of the people who are members of my community, myself, my family,
and you who are here in attendance tonight? So thank you.
Welcome, everybody. It's great to have you. Go Cougs.
Thank you. Wow, yeah, this last,
last month or so has been quite, quite a month for us up here.
And I've thought about a lot of things, learned a lot from residents
and shared a lot in return. And I just wanted to make a couple comments.
You know, when we communicate with one another, you can either
assume ill intent from the beginning and begin your relationship that way,
or you can assume good intent and begin it that way and
then make decisions from there. A quote that I like, great minds discuss ideas,
average minds discuss events, and small minds discuss people. Well,
when it came to the tax discussions, some people kept it at the idea
level, and ideas were going back and forth. Then at the end of the day,
after ideas were discussed, people could say, well,
I agree with that approach, or I don't agree with that approach, but it didn't
get personal. It was just, I have a different managerial style or a different vision.
And there's no animosity in that. But I found there were a lot
of people that stayed down at the people level instead of discussing
ideas level, and they just wanted to attack character and attack,
you know, just attack and assume ill intent.
And I don't think that's safe for a marriage.
And when you have a marriage companionship, you know, you should hopefully assume
good intent and that if there's been a miscommunication, it's usually been There's been a
miscommunication, but I'm grateful for the for
the residents that that kept the discussion on ideas because
when that happened, solutions came out and bridge building came
out. And I think that's a lot where we where we need to keep keep
our discussions at the idea at the idea stage instead of it attacking
character stage. And I recognize as public officials we're going to
get you know we're going to get some of the character attacks and that that's
going to happen and. I would just invite people to come meet with us first
and then make a decision if you want to about our character after you come
actually meet with us. We live in your same neighborhoods. We ride
the same, drive on the same roads, go to the same schools, cheer for the
same Cedar Valley High School football team, and we're in the stands with you.
Just come say hi to us. Come meet us. I homeschool
my kids, and then my kids have done some various things with the public school
as well, and I love the diverse opportunities for learning
because you're right, all, you know, our minds don't,
you know, all think the same way and we do need
different ways to be able to learn and grow. So I'm excited
to have the discussion a little bit later about that school you have going in.
Thanks for bringing that. And that, again, that's the idea phase,
right? The ideas that bring solutions. That's more what we need. We need more
ideas and we're better together when we can share ideas with one another. So Thanks
for your patience with us as we work through this process. I actually
gained more friends from this than I probably gained maybe some enemies as well,
but I don't consider them enemies, and they might consider me an enemy.
But I met some people I didn't know before that I'm like, wow, I have
much respect for, gained greater respect for in this process.
And so I'm grateful for the people that reached out and took the time to
actually get to know us, have legitimate discussions that moved the
city forward.
Yeah, thank you, Anthony, for making that comment.
I had a coworker yesterday, she came to my office and she
said, you're famous. I was like, really? She said, yeah,
my daughter's been following everything on your city on TikTok.
Like, that's not how I wanted to get famous,
but that's okay. Everybody now in America knows
about property taxes in Eagle Mountain.
You know, I look at all the positives that have come from this.
Tonight we're proposing code that would not have existed
had we not had an active conversation in the city. We'll hopefully
be putting in place a safety fund that when you pay your
property tax, 100% of That
will go into a safety fund segregated from sales tax. That's something
that didn't— has never existed, as far as I know, in our city.
We'll be creating, hopefully, if it passes, a rebalancing
mechanism for city councils to not just kick the can down the
road, you know, to have some kind of mechanism. Do we need to save up
for a car? Do we need to consider that we
are having triplets, and how do we plan for that?
We're also going to be
working on a budget in brief, a very simple 10-page
document that is at an 18-year-old level. Somebody who can vote can
read it and understand what's happening in the budget for the next
year. So there's a lot of positive things I think that came from it.
There's some negative things. There are certainly things that we've learned and things that
we'll work on and improve next go-round. So I look
at it and I think There are a lot of positive things that have come
from it. And I'm just grateful. I think the
one thing that we all have in common is we all love Eagle Mountain and
we all want what's best. And sometimes that's gonna be crossing
swords and sharpening our swords. But I, you know, I love what Craig's
comment was. If we can focus on the ideas and
come together with the best ideas, that's a huge positive.
Thank you. So anyways, I'm just grateful. I'm grateful
for the residents. I'm grateful for the process. It has been difficult,
but I'm thankful for where we're landed.
All right, thank you. Appreciate the comments. And just add that, yeah, I too love
the things that we've learned. I look around and I think of all the
really, really smart people, and one of them might be Scott Hazard.
Smartest guys I know in the city. And when I was
able to talk to him about some of the things that we were working on,
he says, well, I didn't know that. I'm like, I knew something that Scott didn't
know? That was like floored me, right? So it was, uh, it was definitely
a learning experience, and especially with people that I really look up to,
uh, to be able to do that. I also, uh,
did get the opportunity to live next to the Ayus, and I really appreciate their
ideas, uh, although I'm not going to admit whether it was my brother or not
that might put a U in your front yard or not. I don't know
anything about that, but I know that he also got
one, so it might not have been him. But no, it's super
fun to be neighbors. You're actually— you didn't know this, but on the other side
of the hill, your backyards almost touch. So just on the other side
of the hill. But the— yeah, it's super fun to
see everybody come with their ideas. And I love the
public when they get to come out and I thought Melissa would say it.
I'm actually disappointed. When people come and yell at us like that,
it's just people caring loudly, right? Isn't that the show from Parks
and Rec, right? I just hear people caring loudly. So no,
it's super fun. So thanks for all your input. I was gonna add
the last few, last month has been a whirlwind,
but we had the opportunity to go spend some time saving
the city a lot of money. I think, over the years. And last
week, me and a couple of staffers went back to New York
and was able to help improve our bond rating. Just the work
that was done there and the things that our staff does and our consultants,
we had Laura Lewis with us, and it's just amazing.
And then the people that were here trying to meet deadlines on,
with the county and getting agendas ready. Thank you. And our
attorneys reviewing documents and just the planning staff.
Everybody was just, it has been a whirlwind. And so grateful
for all the work that we're getting done and even constrained that we're
able to really, really move the needle, I feel like, and do some cool things
and hopefully save a lot of money and be able to keep that budget lean.
So with that, I think we'll get started. And I
know the first item We talked about in the, the work session, the consent agenda
item 12A might get moved to the— Yep.
Would you accept a motion, Mayor? Yes, sir. Yes, ma'am. Mayor, I move that
the City Council approve the consent agenda, removing item 12A from
the consent agenda and placing it on the scheduled items section
of the agenda. Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember
Clark and a second by Councilmember Wright. And we'll start the vote with Councilmember
Hewish. Yes. Councilmember Clark. Yes.
Councilmember Wright. Yes. Councilmember Whiting.
Yes. Just, I just wanted to double-check. Councilmember Wood never, he did not join,
right? Okay. Just making sure I didn't miss a vote.
That passes 4 to 0. And we'll go
right to item 12A, the Gateway Park.
And I know, Steven, turn it to you.
All right. Thank you.
Do you have a screen coming?
I'm patient this time.
All right.
Okay. Yeah, it seems like some of you are familiar with this. That's why it's
been pulled off the agenda. This is a preliminary plat. Applications kind
of come through quickly in attempts to help the proposed school to meet deadlines
that they have to get this open when they want to. So the
property we're dealing with is near the intersection of Mount
Airy Drive and Corby Ride Highway. So it's just west of
Enbridge here and And Eagle Mountain Storage. So it's this little area here.
Here's a shot of the preliminary
plat. So it's a 3-lot plat.
Lot 1 is where the proposed school would be. It's a 6-acre lot.
And then lots 2 and 3 would be, I'm guessing,
just later phases of this development.
Here's it again. So, go back to this.
So, as I'm looking at this, our Transportation
Master Plan, so this is Wagstaff Way, so this would be the north end of
that preliminary plat, and then this road is there on the western edge, just some
context. So we're looking at a future minor
arterial and then a future collector road.
So, this is, this plat that we're dealing with tonight,
And then kind of gives you some context there is that you look at the
Spring Run Plaza development, so you can kind of see where Wagstaff Way
is looking to connect there. There will be a gap for the time being as
those 2 roads develop, um, but eventually those will come together and form that connection.
Uh, as we're reviewing it, there were 2 points that we want to bring up.
So the first one is our code doesn't allow on preliminary
plats to have lots front arterial and collector streets.
Uh, in this case, I think staff's comfortable with allowing that,
seeing as unless— like, we, we talked to the developer— unless they can find a
way to do it, it's kind of tricky to do with a school and have
them still function the way they need to. Uh, right now, the school's been
proposing 2, um, ingress-egress points out of their
property, and they're as far away from the intersection as possible. So we
were— we think with the other 2 lots, We're looking at maybe 1 or 2
or 3 additional points out onto
those collector roads. So I feel like if it's— it's not necessarily
an important standard to hold to in this case.
And then the second one would be that western collector road.
Go back. So this one right here, right now the developer is proposing it be
named Gateway Park Boulevard. This will
eventually connect up to Wild Blossom Boulevard in Saratoga
Springs. With our recent code change that was approved,
and just looking at it, I think staff feels that that name
of Wild Blossom should probably continue just for coherency. Yes, it does,
it will split the boundary between Saratoga Springs and Eagle Mountain, but I think
it'll just create coherency on that road and make it easier to traverse and to
find addresses and— Thank you. the cohesion between
those 2. So those are the 2, um, conditions— that,
that be renamed, and then if we're okay with not
letting them have those access points onto the roads.
I asked for this to be removed from the consent agenda because I want to
talk about the name of the road. I get
that for our code we've made it a priority for us
to have roads contiguous have the same name.
However, I think where I draw the line with that is where
it runs into another city. Um, we have Woodhaven
that is going to eventually connect to something over in Saratoga Springs,
and we have Silver Lake Parkway that's going down to eventually connect
with the new high school. And I don't see on any planet us
Entertaining changing the name once it gets to a certain
point, and Wild Blossom is a very design-specific
name for the housing development
that's there. And we have other streets in
that general vicinity: Ranches Parkway, we have Spring
Run, and I just think that. The project
in this area will be better served with sticking to
the overall name of Gateway Park Boulevard.
One, I just had a question. I know I don't have a lot of say
on this, but the driveway situation, I know staff said they
didn't mind or that maybe it fit. I just wanted to raise the question
what we've done in the past, and specifically residential. This— I
don't remember the parking lot, but can you go back to the— well, actually,
speaking of Woodhaven, there are 3 homes that are on basically
on Woodhaven, and we've cut that, uh, you know, there's that
big C-shaped half moon so that if someone was backing out
of their driveway, they could get forward and go out. Is it, uh— I
don't have my stuff, but with the plat,
is there room to make some kind
of a cutout like that, would that address a concern? I think you just have
to ask the developer that question, Mayor, because it really is dependent upon the internal,
the internal construction. Well, and I think my, my point was
with council, if we're not okay, would that be a solution? I just wanted to
point that out, and, and I'm happy to let you address that if there is
a concern. I don't know there is. I just wanted to bring that because
it was addressed. Go ahead.
Okay, is this not work— oh hey, it's working now. It wasn't working a week
ago. Um, Scott Hazard, I'm, I'm the developer,
one of the applicants. Uh, to answer your question, Mayor,
these are not 6, 8, 10,000 square foot lots. This is a 6-acre parcel.
Um, the intention you heard earlier is for a charter school site, so they'll have
circulated egress that comes One off of Wagstaff Way and then
one off of Gateway Park Boulevard,
if you so see it that way.
There really is no way to load this internally. If you recall the
collaboration for Wagstaff Way and for Gateway Park Boulevard,
these collectors and arterials that run through our 600-acre master
plan that we'll be bringing to you shortly, we're advancing this. Thank you. us accelerate
it more quickly to meet the timeline of the charter school. Um, but this—
all of those, uh, larger roadways were,
were programmed and designed in collaboration with, uh,
David Salazar and with the, with city staff. They did not exist
when we put in the original, uh, Gateway Park improvements with the storage garages,
the flex space, the Enbridge facility, etc. So there
was no contemplation to try to work an internal road to try to
create like a little horseshoe or half moon is just a waste
of property, I think, on a 6-acre lot. The other lots are not 6 acres,
but they're also significant in size.
And the south side of Wagstaff Way, so between
Wagstaff Way and State Road 73, is a tapering traffic
route according to our modeling because it connects to a right-in,
right-out. Most of the traffic will, in the
modeling, will either go to Spring Run Parkway, the signalized
full-service intersection when UDOT expands that facility,
or it'll go eastbound to Mount Airy Drive where there's another signalized
intersection. Scott, that was one of the questions that I had. Mayor, may I just
jump in here? And it's really, so until UDOT does the expansion,
what is the plan for the connectivity to Whatever
the name of this road is going to be. Yeah, this kind of the S-shape
that you have right now for the right-in, right-out, is that going to— are you
guys— is that going to be developed? So that's what we'll connect to. That S-curve
has been paved from— I mean, it's been paved for a really long time.
So that was permitted when we sold the corridor preservation
parcel to UDOT. We sold them about 8 acres along our frontage.
We wanted to maintain the access. We put the permit in. Typically, the permit
requires a road like that to be on a property line,
but in this case it didn't because of the topography. We had to create— UDOT
required us to create a safe egress road, which required us to
kind of run that up parallel grade and snake it up the hill. So that's
why it's snaky, is because it's going up that hill.
The property line's smack in the middle of it, if you can see that yellow
line. So when UDOT's facilities in there, what does that look like? Is it a
right-in, right-out right at the base of where the mayor's cursor's at? It'll tie to
a frontage road. So when UDOT expands— so for now it goes to the right-in,
right-out on the existing facility. Right now the program— the programming
for the expansion design is when it's completed, it'll tie to the frontage road,
and then the freeway or arterial traffic will
go in the middle, similar to what you see at 2100 North. I think
it's a similar road profile. Thank you. I think what I was gonna say,
my point when I was talking about the C or the half-moon entrances onto
the lot, was there residential lots and they're backing out? There won't
be anybody backing out onto the collector. No, all of this is charter school,
and then there's these other 2 lots here that are intended to mirror
a use that's similar to what we did here, some flex space or something along
those lines. So showing these entrances, they're gonna be pulling out into the
road just like any other? Correct. And you'll see that
on the site plan for the charter school when it comes before you to determine
whether or not the way they're proposing that access and circulation makes
sense to you. But from what I've seen, they're looking to access one
here on Wagstaff Way and then circulate out here onto Gateway
Park Boulevard. If I could just say one thing about Gateway Park Boulevard,
obviously we're not excited to brand a major master planned community
in another city, which is why we're proposing the name change. And because we're a
significant grouping or massing of land,
we've got about 600 acres there eventually, we wanted it to be
destination-oriented. We're— when you're on Ranches Parkway, you're in
the ranches and you know that. So, but Wild Blossom is primarily
an east-west road. It only curves
to the south at the very last little bit to connect into our
north property line. So the vast majority of that right-of-way going north-south
would be a whole different coordinate set. So I think that should
be taken into consideration in addition to we're crossing a boundary with another
city. And I just wanted to add one more thing as you talk master plan
for the council to consider. If the entrances are,
say, here and here that we just talked about, without a master
plan, is there any kind of an assurance that we could
have that The future development of something over here is not going to have an
entrance, you know, they're going to line up is what I'm getting at. They're not
going to be offset intersections so that if you have an entrance,
you know, here, that you'd also have one here to a business
on this side. Yeah, so this,
this is programmed as a commercial lot. Um,
so, Mayor, I get the, I get the point, and I think we can work
to make sure that that's safe. I'm sure whatever we bring for development on this,
we would collaborate with staff and try to have some intelligent safe design
there. This parcel is becoming more and more constrained
due to the RCA approval that at best is creating an
18-foot cut where it hits my southern property line, which really
affects the ability— like, I can't load from this lot on that
whole side, and I can't for hundreds and hundreds of feet to the north because
I just— it's a tunnel. So I'm going to have
to load somewhat from Wagstaff Way or from this side to be
able to even make that property work. I just want to make sure there's some
kind of contemplation of lining that up.
This— what if you're going to load off this side, that there's a—
they're across from each other? Yeah, I think we could work to make sure that
that makes sense moving forward. Just know that it'll most likely have to load
from that side because we have new constraints that we didn't anticipate on the west.
I'm ready to make a motion. I think we should call it IU Boulevard instead,
but I'll make this motion. Craig,
before you do that, can I just ask a question? Oh, yeah, go ahead.
How does the council feel about the name? I think Gateway Park Boulevard.
I like it. It comes to me, it comes down to branding, and we're a
different city, so I'm okay having it be— Okay, that's what I wanted to hear.
Okay, so I move that City Council approve the Gateway Park Plat 3 preliminary plat
with condition number 1, omitting condition
number 2. Second.
Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting and a second by Councilmember
Clark, and we'll start the vote with Councilmember Clark? Yes. Councilmember Wright?
Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes. Councilmember Hewish? Yes.
Okay, that motion passes. Thank you.
Appreciate your time. And we'll move to item 14—
nope, 15A. And that's an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City,
Utah, amending the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code to repeal
and replace Section 1760130,
regarding retaining walls and construction standards.
Um, we'll invite Vince. There you are.
You probably see me here a little better, I think.
Mayor and Council, it's good to be with you. We'll get this pulled up here
and we can get started.
Okay. I'll warn you, this is a lot of
engineering and technical stuff that we're going to talk about.
Hopefully you have your engineering hats on.
As I've been here for the last couple years, this is
one of the codes that has come up kind of over and over again,
not just from an engineering standpoint, but from planning and from
our building inspectors. And it became
pretty obvious that there were some weaknesses in the previous code that we wanted to
address. And so, This is a conglomeration
of engineering and planning and the building inspectors
all meeting together and kind of coming up with what we think is best.
So why we're updating the standard. The old
standard, if you remember, it had specific
types of materials called out and And it was kind of
based on those specific types of walls or types
of materials of walls. We wanted to go away from that a
little bit and base it more on an engineering basis.
There was nothing in the old code about surcharge loading on top of these
walls. And we'll talk a little bit more about what surcharge load
is in just a minute. But we wanted to address that.
Height limits, a set 6-foot for absolutely
everything. A lot of requests for variances to this,
and so we tried to address that one too.
And then in the old code, there was no formal inspection program required.
And so once it got through the city review process,
they would go out and build it, and it wasn't always built according to what
we had specced out.
So to kind of simplify things, we said,
let's just divide this into 2 main categories,
prescriptive gravity walls and engineering retaining walls.
The gravity walls are just 4-foot walls maximum.
Someone wants to go in their backyard and build a kind of a rock wall
in their backyard, as long as it's 4-foot tall and no surcharge
on the top, that's perfectly fine. No permit required.
The city would still look at it, obviously, but no building permit required
for that. And the
one thing we would look at is surcharging. You know, are we parking cars
on top of this? Is it being built up for a parking pad or an
RV pad? Is a building or a shed or
something going to be on top of it? Those are the kind of things that
you would see in a surcharge situation. And then
the other thing you'd look at for surcharges is the
Is there a slope on top of the wall that comes up to the top
of the wall, and is it flat or is it actually sloped? Because if it's
sloped, then there's actually more loading on that because of the slope.
So those are the things we looked at, and this is kind of the way
we defined our two walls.
So this was the main complaint from the the building inspectors: is it
wasn't clear when actual building. Permit was needed
and when it was not. And so we tried to clarify this in saying,
you know, the gravity walls, 4-foot, no surcharge, then no building permit.
If it's above 4-foot or if it has any kind of
surcharge, no matter what the height, it would definitely need a building permit
to go forward with that. So we tried to fix that
little issue in the code.
Height standards. Like I mentioned before, 6 foot was,
was really the max for any type of wall height.
What we have proposed in this is that in residential properties,
keep that same 6 foot height. I think that's reasonable for most residential properties.
And then in the commercial industrial areas where they have bigger buildings
and bigger parking lots that need more flat area,
move that up to 10 foot to allow them to flatten things out and
to use their property.
And then obviously that 10 foot is clearly in the building permit range,
and it's also in the range where we would
look at it really close on an engineering standpoint.
Multiple tiers. of retaining walls. This was
in the previous code, but the tier length
between the walls was 1.5 times the height.
We propose to change that, and this came from the building inspector's request
that that is changed to 2 to 1. So if you have
a 6-foot wall, it's 12 foot before you can actually put another retaining wall.
And that actually corresponds with the
International Building Code, and so we're actually just kind of mirroring What
the International Building Code, or IBC, says on that one.
And then, if for some reason it has to be less than
that, if there's constraints in the property, then it has to be built and
designed as a single wall system.
And in engineering terms, it basically means they have
to do the geotech for both walls, looking at them both not independently as different
walls, but as one wall system.
So, as part of that, and actually this applies not
just to the tiers, but to everything, we better defined exactly what
was submitted to the engineering department and to planning as
far as engineering requirements.
In the old code, it basically had to be stamped by a professional engineer,
and we kind of relied on that stamp. Now we're actually
going to be reviewing a lot more information— lateral
pressure, seismic loading, the drainage, bearing capacity, those kind
of things— so that we're looking specifically at each wall, because each wall is,
is going to be a little bit different. And so we want to look at
the calculations behind where they got to and just make sure that
we agree with those things before we're approving those on an engineering basis.
Thank you.
And then I mentioned this one, inspection requirements.
The previous code didn't have any inspection requirements, and this defines—
there's a list of multiple inspections in there.
We don't necessarily have to do every single inspection that's listed
in there, but it says we can, and it really allows our building inspectors to
be able to go out and check they need to check and, and look at
the things that they want to look at as these things are getting built.
Um, the one exception to that is the
mechanically stabilized earth walls.
Those walls, um, they're the walls that you see
UDOT put up when they're building a roadway way,
way up above, and, and they're 20, 30-foot tall walls,
and it's— it looks like concrete panel
paneling is what it looks like. But those panels are anchored back into the soil,
and so the soil behind it is really what, what is holding that wall
up. And that's— it's very critical to get proper materials,
proper compaction, and those kind of things. And so that's why we said on
those walls, we, we want to— we will require
inspections on those, and we want to see the tests on the compaction
and those kind of things, just so we're We're making sure those are being built
in a safe manner.
And then property line and easement standards.
The old standard was the wall, the face of the wall had to be 3
feet from a property line. And we're actually saying, yeah, we kind of
agree with that because it clearly defines on whose property that wall is.
And if there's an issue with it, it's clearly defined who needs
to deal with it or address it. Where if it's right on the property line,
I think that's where this code originated from. If it's right on the property line
and there's an issue with it, then you have the 2 neighbors arguing
over whose wall it is and who built it and those
kind of things. And so I think to avoid that, that's where this code originated
from. And we propose that we keep
that language in here. Now, we did add some language.
If you have a retaining wall, like on the back of a property that's going
on multiple lots, there's no reason to do a
small retaining wall and then stop, and then have another retaining wall in the
next lot and stop, and have another. We can have a continuous retaining
wall across all of those. But in that case,
it's typically built by the developer, and he's building it as
one cohesive. coherent or one cohesive system.
And so we would be looking at that as the developer comes
in and comes in for approval and those kind of things. But we
said that that is allowable to go across
property lines in a perpendicular manner.
Vince? Yes. With that, it talks about how if all owners
agree At that point when it's being approved
and whatnot by the city to a developer, really probably only
has one owner at that point. Are we looking to get some
future owner information, or is there going to be some sort of disclosure
in like the real estate documents? Like, or is
it just better than it used to be?
Right, right. We didn't define that in this because we were
mostly just looking at the technical side. But yeah, I think what
we were thinking is if you come in after the fact, 2 neighbors want to
put in one retaining wall and they're separate
owners. If it comes in as a developer, I think it's the same owner and
they can still put it in how they want. Okay, thank you.
Yep. The other change that we had was the The PUE
that is on the back side of most lots, or even on
the side of most of our lots in the city, that public
utility easement has some restrictions. And in the old code,
it said we couldn't have any kind of retaining wall on the PUE,
which was actually a conflict with the 3-foot rule because most of our PUEs
are either 5-foot or 10-foot offset from that property line.
So with that one, we basically modified it to
be similar to if someone comes in and wants to put a
sign in our PUE, they have to come to us for an exception.
It has to be looked at and approved, but we would allow retaining walls
in that PUE now with the new code.
So yeah, that's really a summary of all the changes we made to the
code. Open it up for any questions you guys have.
I don't really have a question, maybe just a comment, Vince. I mean,
great job, number one. Thank you for taking an engineer's
look at this. I think it's actually really
well done. My only concern is with 5B, and I
just I, I, I don't think we should leave multifamily properties
in the, in the approved for a 10-foot wall height because I
think that just encourages hillside development, which I want to stay away from anyway.
So that would be my only comment, that, and that's something I'd ask the council
to do is consider removing the word multifamily from 5B.
Obviously we have a public hearing and, and, and other things,
so I don't really have any other questions. That, that's my only comment. Just my,
my question being, So the 3-foot wall face, does it really have to be 3
feet to make sure people know whose wall it is? Can we make it a
little sooner, closer? That's what he changed. No, I think he said that's what it
was. Yeah, it's still 3 feet from the property line. Yeah,
but the footing is 1 foot. It's 1 foot for the footing.
So you're 1 foot from the footing from the property line, and then you're the
center of the wall. So if you have a 2-foot, I guess it's a little
further away than that. It just depends how big the footing is.
Right, right. And it doesn't necessarily have to be three foot,
but it would have a footing on the wall.
So if you're on the lower side of that, even though
the face of the wall is three foot, or maybe it would be close,
take care of it. If if it's built right on the property line,
now you're in your neighbor's yard taking care of it if you need to.
So for me, that makes complete sense.
The other question I had was. Maybe I missed it,
but I think it's 6B.
When you're talking— or is it C? 6A or C?
When you're talking about tiered walls, so the base wall and then the second wall
that's tiered back. Yep. There's no definition, at least I couldn't—
you have the length, but is there that gap that you're asking for? It doesn't
say how much. Twice the width. 12 feet? I mean, you can have—
if you have So if you go 4 feet and you go back 2 feet
and go another 4? Right, then it's considered a single wall.
Yep. So yeah. So then my question
is, even on the industrial at 10 feet,
I used to build a lot of these, and whether it's block or whatever,
at some point on anything over 6 feet, they'd have
to have a mesh or an engineered Yeah,
kind of an anchor system. Anchor. Yeah, I'm sorry. That would also get
buried behind that wall to keep the middle of the wall from bulging out.
Sure. So is that also— if
we're going to go to 10 feet, I'm just curious if that's something that we
need to, especially if it's load-bearing.
Yeah, that is something we would look at in our engineering review. We didn't
spell that out specifically in the code, but in the It requires a permit.
Yeah, it requires a permit, and it requires submittals of
all the calculations. And so as part of those calculation checks, we would look at
that. Does it need to be anchored to have stability? Do you think that the
code would protect us a little bit knowing that anything over 6 feet is going
to most likely require that, that we should at least say
something like that? Right. I think with our
engineering check, we could check and verify those things as they come in.
We could add it to the code explicitly if you want,
but I think it's— Is there any—
is there ever a time when you're going over 6 feet and we're talking about
10 feet that you wouldn't require it?
Yes, it would depend on the type of the wall that they're building. Like a
thick concrete wall with a big footing on it wouldn't necessarily have to have anchors
on it. So yeah, it's a solid wall.
If it's a solid wall. Correct, correct. Solid wall.
Yep. If you feel comfortable. Okay, so is there any other questions
for Vince? We do have a public hearing, so nothing there. All right,
thank you. Um,
with that, it is 7:58 and this is a public hearing,
so I will open the public hearing and ask Lacey
if anyone— nobody turned in anything. Is there anyone here that would
like to speak on this item that did not get the opportunity? Seeing no
one, at 7:58, we will close the public hearing and bring it back to
the council for further discussion. I'll make a motion unless there's concerns.
Anybody have anything they want to add before we do that? Melissa? I just— I
want to say this. I'm really grateful that we're doing this. I think that engineering
and staff did a really great job in preparing this code. But some
of them are contingent on whoever is
working in the department at the time and what inspections
and things that they're going to require. I want us to always make sure
that the culture of our city is that we require the
inspections and the engineering plans and all of those things because there are places
in our city where this hasn't been done, and I want to make sure that
that doesn't change. as we have different staff members over the years.
So I think I'm calling on our Building and
Engineering and Community Development Department to just really make sure
that we make these inspections and
permits our goal and our culture in our city.
Thank you.
Entertain a motion, Mayor. I move that the Eagle
Mountain City Council approve an ordinance amending the municipal code to
repeal and replace Section 17.60.130 regarding
retaining wall construction standards with the change
of removing the multifamily, the word multifamily from
item 5B. Second.
Okay, we have a motion and a second. The motion by Councilmember Wright and a
second by Councilmember Whiting. Do we— sorry, go ahead.
Do we need to have Can we have them move or in front
of institutional, or is that inherent for staff
to be able to make that change? I'll amend my motion to include the word
or. Thank you. Second. Okay,
is there any other questions on the motion? The, uh,
motion stands with Councilmember Wright and a second by Councilmember Whiting, and we'll start
the vote with Councilmember Wright. Yes. Councilmember Whiting. Yes.
Councilmember Huish? Yes. And Councilmember Clark? Yes. Okay,
that item passes, and we will move to item 5B.
This is a— or sorry,
15B, you're right. An ordinance of Eagle
Mountain City rezoning certain lands known as the Pinnacles, approving the Pinnacles Master
Development Plan and Master Development Agreement Amendment.
And I believe Robert is ready. Good evening,
Mayor and Council. At the heart of this particular matter is simply
a request to rezone 3 parcels, properties of land,
aggregated about 14 acres— sorry for the typo in the report— from
their commercial neighborhood setting or zoning to agriculture.
This is based on a request, of course, by an applicant representing that they
have an interest in temporarily making this happen to effectively save money on
their tax bill, understandably so. The zoning
assigned to the project which
you see on the screen before you as far as location.
That's the Pinnacles, which is over north of Aviator and west of Pony
Express. Was something that was inculcated
into a development agreement memorialized back in the fall of 2022.
At that time, the Pinnacles set aside the properties that you see on your screen
for, again, commercial neighborhood, with the balance of the project into
some form of residential a different kind of commercial up at the top,
if you will, and then off to the west or to the left of the
image, area for townhouses, which has been already reviewed and approved.
As part of this action, if council's favorable with the idea,
by association you have also the
requirement, of course, to amend your future land use map so
that it harmonizes with the new zoning. And then because this was made part—
this whole affair was made part of a development agreement set with the master development
plan, those 2 items also need to be amended. But mainly it's housekeeping.
It's just simply saying we're okay with this new
zoning here, this ag zoning, and therefore we're going to amend the master development
plan and agreement, especially paragraph 3.2, and then our future
land use map to all fall in line with that decision.
Any questions? So is the motivation for
this is to save money on property tax? Yes, and there was some discussion at
the Planning Commission, who by the way advanced a favorable recommendation on this request,
as to whether that was going to happen with the zoning of
the property being changed. And their understanding that everyone walked
away with was basically, yes, we think that will happen. And the applicant explained the
why for and how for of that. So assuming they're here tonight, And they can
also go into detail on that matter if you'd like them to.
And we haven't had any contact from outside parties or communications, whether by phone
or email or visitation, that have discussed this matter with us other than just the
That's it.
No questions for staff?
Just making sure there is public hearing, so I can go to that if you're
okay. We'll go ahead
and hold the public hearing. It is 8:04, and we'll open the public hearing
and ask Lacey if she's seen anybody come forward. No one.
Okay. Is there anyone here who wants to speak on this item?
Seeing no one, I will close the public hearing
at 8:04 and bring it back to the council. I do know the applicant.
The applicant is here, and is there
any questions for the applicant? Anything?
Any discussion? Anything? I'll share some thoughts.
I mean, let me just share some thoughts. I'm opposed to this,
to granting this, and certainly not with any desire
or willingness to be punitive towards an applicant that wants to reduce their taxes.
So let me state that publicly for you, Andy, so that you hear that.
That's not the reason that I'm opposed to this.
This was part of an MDP, it was part of an MDA, it was part
of a negotiation to develop this entire area,
which included giving some multifamily densities in this
area. And the tradeoff, at least in my mind, was that
we were going to ensure that there's some commercial development that comes in there along
Aviator. I think by choosing to move this back to Ag, what we do
in a sense is we reset the table and we say,
come back and petition a future council to do whatever you'd like. You can still
do that with the neighborhood commercial resident designation,
zoning designation. It's just it requires the
council to then understand the context of where it's been and
why. So at least for So for me, that's where I'm feeling
some hesitancy to want to do this because of that.
So— Sorry, I was just— Marcus, I just can't remember on—
as far as greenbelt exemptions, you can get greenbelt in
any zone, right? So even commercial zone could get a greenbelt or an
ag exemption as long as there's an agricultural use, right?
So plant a cherry tree, harvest Sell
a cherry. It's been a minute since I've looked at that code. I think it
has to be ag-zoned or something similar to that. So I don't think you can
greenbelt. I know. But I'm not 100%
certain on that without researching. Residential qualifies for greenbelt, right? So I'd
have to look at that. I don't know if this is 5 acres or more.
I don't know how— Right. If it's 5 acres or more, which I don't remember
the property. Yeah, it's plenty over 5. Plenty over 5,
okay. Yeah, so I'd have to look at that. I'm not certain.
Just a thought that there could be some tax savings if there was an
avenue to go. Go ahead, Greg. I think
going back to Council Member Wright's point, I think that this was part of a
larger negotiation with some give and take, and one
of those, and it landed upon this particular grouping
of approvals. And so it's
sort of, it was taken as a whole when it was approved.
I will say that when it came previously, it was way
more dense, like the property to the east, and the
council at the time was the one that was pushing to have additional
commercial right there. So like, I feel like
that was an ask of people from our city. As opposed
to the developer per se. So I'm— I get why
they would like to reset that piece for tax purposes and
really determine viability down the road so that when
it does come back, a future council can look at what
the best use of it is. I do understand the hesitancy
because what it does is it puts the responsibility
on a future council. To do their homework and really understand what's going on with
that piece. But I would hope that our staff reports have
come such a long way from what they used to be that they
could provide that context in the staff report and
even older documents to show what it once was.
But am I allowed to make a comment here? Yeah, I'll let you speak.
Zap can address the concern. All right, thank you. This is— my name is Andy
Flamm. I represent represent the property owners. I just wanted
to say, when this first was negotiated, or I guess that's the
right word, negotiated and contemplated with the city, it happened over several years.
And one of the concerns was 800 North in
Orem. There's a lot of traffic on 800
North, and there's a lot of old homes that are having to get purchased and
redeveloped. And forward thinking,
This was determined in meetings with the Planning Commission and staff
and others that we wanted to preserve some commercial corridor
right here in anticipation of a future freeway.
I don't know when that will be, but it was a good idea
and I supported it and I thought it was a great compromise.
I still do. The development agreement— this was actually approved in
the fall of '21. So the development agreement actually expires
next year, if I remember right. But so we
would have to come back if we rezoned this property to
anything else in the future, and that development agreement probably
wouldn't even apply at that time anyway. But the
reason why I'm here trying to rezone it back to ag, which is something you
probably rarely see, is when we put
in— Never. Never. When the roads were put in,
when we had to detain— retain water on our site for Aviator,
we lost our greenbelt status and we're getting killed.
And to get it back in, we're told that we need to get it in
ag, and we're working with some leases to get it back in because right
now we've had this thing on the market for
a year and a half. We've talked to a lot of people. There's no demand
for commercial on a dead-end road at this time. Now, there will be, and we
believe in that vision of having this be commercial in the future. But until then,
we're just getting killed on taxes. And I know that's been a hot
topic, but when you actually look at taxes
in general, property taxes, but when you look at what actually goes to the city
from this site, and most of it's going to the county or the school district
or whatnot. Our application fee tonight to
even just do this rezone probably put the city
ahead already. So again,
we were trying to be— or we were, I felt like, a good
partner when we brought this project forward. There was a lot of discussion
and what the city wants, and we were Again,
we're not asking to change to high-density residential,
which I've been in so many meetings in here where an applicant comes back and
says, we tried for a year. Well, this is 6 years in and there's
still no demand for commercial. And so anyway,
that's the ask. I just wanted to give a little bit more context to it
just because I know there's some new faces from when this originally came
forward. But any other questions for me? from the council or the mayor? Go ahead.
Yeah, sorry, I looked at the Act and I mean,
so technically you could get greenbelt status in a commercial zone, but it's
not a permitted use. So,
and it sounds like if they lost greenbelt status, it's because they're not engaging in
Act uses, which means there's no nonconforming use.
So they couldn't get greenbelt status in a commercial zone because
it would be a nonconforming use. Unless we made some kind of exception or—
Well, no, I mean, they're asking to rezone it.
So then they obviously— ag would be a permitted use. They could get their
greenbelt status back. We've got the rest of the property fenced and we've
got leases. And this— it was a dry farm historically,
but when they came in and they had a grade to put in the retention
ponds on the 3 different parcels, County just
happened to come out right when that was all graded, and so anyway,
we didn't have the new crop out, and we lost that status. So anyway,
another question that I wonder if we'd consider is the
future land use map would, with an expired MDA,
as long as it was on the future land use map as neighborhood
commercial, would that guide a council to that? And then could you write
a one-page Agreement would extend it at least six
years on this piece. It says that it's intended to be,
you know, because it's going to expire anyway. I mean, all that's a possibility.
Totally supportive of keeping the the land use map
with commercial. We're not intending to change that. That's that's
not what this is about. No, and you know, and my my concern again,
I'll just restate it. This is a perfect place for someone
to come back in if it's rezoned. Zone to ag and ask to build multifamily
housing in this area. And for me, it's just— that's a nonstarter.
It's intended to be commercial. I understand that perhaps the viability of that is
not today. But we
had this conversation, at least I wasn't here at the time, so it predates me.
2021, I wasn't here. I think you were at Planning Commission maybe at
the time. I was on Planning Commission at that time. And so Look,
I've stated my objection. The others may feel differently than that. That's where I'm going
to land. Um, Councilmember Wright, do you feel like the land use
designation on the future land use map
helps to kind of set the vision for this area? Because we have lots of
areas that we as a city have returned
to ag because we wanted that to be like the base level, and then
they have to come and ask for something different. Do I— and
the reason for that, at least in my mind, is because we wanted to reset
that so that it would come to something that we want rather than what it
was. Okay. And for me, commercial makes sense here. It's just—
and it already has that designation, and it's part of a larger agreement.
I think that's the— for me, at least, the hurdle that I'm not able to
get over. What about the expiration of the larger agreement? Because that is something
that went into place when you were on Planning, and I was— the
MDA will expire in 6 years, right? We want those things to reset,
and it's really a question of what does this council want? Does this
council want to see this maintained as a, as a commercial area, or do we
want to reset it to, to ag? I've stated my objection to
it. The rest of you can do what you want. Okay, thank you.
So even if, even if the future land use map shows commercial, you still feel
like that there's That they're— There's nothing on the
future land use map that dictates that it's going to happen. The zoning requires
this to be commercial now. That's the difference in
my mind. It's no different than what we dealt with on the north end of
the city where we have these mixed uses and it says, we'll try to pursue
commercial uses in this area and it always ends up residential. For me,
it's protecting some of those commercial uses in an area that I think we're going
to want and need it. We had an applicant
who came before us and wanted to build a 12-plex on that commercial lot where
Freddy's is at now. So I think it's the same argument that
I've seen time and time again. It's the same movie.
I'll make a motion, Mayor, if you want, and, and then we'll find out where
the rest of these guys are at. How does that sound? Do it. If you're
willing to let me do that, let me get I got to open it up
here. OK. I have it here. I've got
it. Mayor, I move that the Eagle Mountain City Council
deny the reason— the item— what is it?
15B, rezoning certain lands known as Pinnacles
and approving the Pinnacles Master Plan, Master Development
Plan, and Master Development Agreement Amendment. Second.
Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Wright and a second by Councilmember Whiting.
And I think we were here. Councilmember Whiting?
Yes. Councilmember Hewish? Yes. Councilmember Clark?
No. Councilmember Wright? Yes. Okay, that passes 3-1.
Uh, thank you. Let's see, that takes us to item
16A, uh, an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City enacting
Chapter 3.50 of Eagle Mountain Municipal Code
establishing property tax allocations.
Actually, before I move on, I don't think this was a big deal,
but I— when there's one vote, did you want to make any—
do I need to stop or— Oh,
I think it really just comes down to the fact that I think that it
is a good move to reset that land with the
expectation that it's commercial because it's in our future land use
map. And I remember the ask was something that the city asked the landowner of,
so that's why I just felt like it, it made sense
to approve it. But I respect everyone else's right to
make their choices too. Yep. I just— before, I like
everybody to have a chance to explain if they choose. So, uh, yeah,
it's, uh, enacting Chapter 3.15 or 3.50 of the Eagle
Mountain Municipal Code establishing property tax allocations. Um,
I, uh, Evan's got some information, so.
Yes, uh, Mayor and Council, we'll run through this code just to kind of
COVID what's, uh, changed since the last time we talked about it and,
uh, answer any remaining questions. And I will
say right off the bat that, uh, this is definitely not a perfect code.
Uh, it's something that we haven't had before, as was mentioned, And it's
the best shot we're giving it right now. But I expect there'll be some kinks
in it that we'll probably have to work out later as we go through this
process. So we'll work on this together over the next budget
season and see how it goes and modify as needed. But we tried to
cover everything we could with it. So as you recall,
the instructions that we received from the council is to draft
this code. That would essentially allocate the property taxes,
all the property taxes that we receive to public safety
into a public safety fund that would be restricted for those
uses. And then it would establish certain coverage
ratios that we'd then be monitoring from year to year to make sure that
where we need to reduce property taxes 'cause we're collecting too much, we do that.
Where we need to increase property taxes 'cause we don't have enough, we do that.
But then throughout the course of the year, we're also keeping tab on the certain
metrics and, you know, different analysis to make sure that we have a good handle
on where our public safety needs are and that we are tracking this effectively
and transparently for the public so that this is
working as intended. So just to break it down a
little bit for you, and I'll just run through this fairly quickly,
the first couple of pages They go through the purpose and the
general policy, and so you have just essentially breaking down
that what we just said. This is, you know, for property tax
to go into this public safety fund. But I want to call
attention to a couple of things in here. First,
there was, you know, commentary made last time just about
how do we make sure that this this code isn't just something
that we just have, and it's not. I don't want to use the word necessarily
enforced, but we talk about accountability, trying to make sure that it's something that we
are sticking to, that we're not just kind of loosely
adhering to. And so I was trying to come up with some method that
we could do that, some sort of pressure that it puts both on council and
staff to make sure that we move
forward with this vision, but it's also not too
heavily impactful that we start kicking ourselves because of how we're doing this.
And so what I came up with for
now is that essentially we're creating an order of operations with
things wherein we're forcing the
conversation of the public safety side to come earlier or as early
as possible in this, where obviously we know as a growing city, one of
the most important things that we have to monitor is our own staffing levels
citywide. And so we know there's going to be questions
every year about how much staff that we can allocate
for all sorts of city services. But when we're
talking about property tax as kind of that key revenue source that's going to fund
public safety, and with this coverage ratio, knowing that that coverage ratio
may require more sales tax or less sales tax from year to year,
we need to settle that core public service that we offer as
a city, um, first and then talk about the other
staffing stuff later. And when I say later, it's not that finance
can't necessarily start gathering some of that information, start getting some of that
feedback so that we can continue the process as quickly as it needs to
go, but no decisions necessarily by the city council or
their staff will happen with the other staff until the public
safety fund and everything like that has been figured out. If that, hopefully that makes
sense. I also wanted to just call out an attention,
just there's obviously on page 2, there's some definitions. One of the ones
that's another change that I didn't
really notate specific on here is that there's a definition for qualified
public safety costs. I added in there that
some language that makes it clear that facilities falls
under that as well. So we can make sure that we're— we do
have a public safety impact fund already, impact fee fund,
but if there's other revenues we could pull off property tax to help pay debt
service and other things for public safety facilities, then that's worked in there as
well. Um, on pages 3
and 4 talks about the creation of that public safety fund. I did
eliminate a sentence that as I went, so there is specific
state code that talks about the creation of funds for property
tax dollars. And so there was a line that we had in there that I
felt like ran contrary to what state code has in there.
It doesn't make any meaningful change to the code itself that we have
in here. So this is just more of a cleanup item.
The rest of that, there's some stipulations about
making sure that the funds can't just be transferred to and fro for
whatever reasons. It needs to stay in the public safety fund for those public safety
purposes. The coverage ratio evaluations
added some language in there about making
sure that we're collecting some level of service metrics, and those level of service
metrics are gonna be what helps us determine what
is that public safety funding requirement
We're not just throwing out feel-good numbers of how many sheriff's deputies or whatnot
that we need. It has to be supported by evidence.
Pages 5 and 6 goes into additional guidance
on the fund balance, how we handle when we have an increasing or decreasing
fund balance, how do we handle other cost allocations, which is
mostly relevant if the city chooses at some point
to establish its own independent police department will wanna handle things like HR costs and
IT costs and risk management and things like that that often fall in other departments
but then have to get transferred to and from. And then there's the
annual reporting side of things. And with the annual reporting,
I did add a section in there about
making sure that annual reporting or an annual summary makes it to the public.
Earlier in the process so that it's not something where the public's only
finding out about it at the tail end of the budgeting process.
That just as much as you are also receiving that information about the public safety
fund and the public safety needs in our city, the public is
also learning about that through this, you know, similar metrics and things like that and
receiving it in multiple formats.
Besides that, I do want to pass some time to Kimberly.
We talked about this a fair bit and just wanted to give
her some time to kind of talk a little bit about her thoughts on
just how to implement this. And then just some things that would help if
you guys can work together on making sure that the process
keeps moving smoothly as we go through this. So.
So, Mayor and Council, a couple of items just
to kind of keep in mind with this particular code.
So one of the items is the special revenue fund that
we're creating. It will be created from a budgetary purpose,
so it it'll work similar to the way that we have
our water and sewer impact fees. So the
water and sewer Sewer impact fees we separate from a budgetary standpoint,
but in the year-end financial statements those are actually just part of the water fund
and the sewer fund because you can't have a special revenue fund for non-government
activities. Okay, so this there's some accounting provisions
where it's like state code we can do certain things,
but when it comes to the financial statements for accounting, this won't meet
the requirements for an like a separate special revenue fund.
So that's all on our books and the things that we're doing. You'll see
it as a separate fund. We'll budget it separately. But in the year-end financial statements,
it will be grouped up as part of the general fund.
So I just want to make sure that that part is clear.
Then that when we talk about
trying to ensure that decisions have
been made kind of about the funding for public safety before we make decisions
on other things. What those decisions that we're talking about
from the council's perspective is how
much revenue do we need to be able to generate from a property tax
standpoint compared to other revenue resources in relation
to funding public safety with the understanding that
we won't actually receive a certified tax rate until June, which is way past
when we have a tentative budget that has to come to the council.
So when we're talking about making these decisions for the planning and
moving things forward, it's not something that can wait until
the certified tax rate is available. So in Utah, when we're talking
about taxes, it really doesn't have anything to do with the rate.
The rate is just what happens based on the revenue you decide that
you need. Thank you. And that is how it's designed to work.
So it will be looking at that and that we will have
projections from that. And it doesn't prevent you when it gets to the
end and you get your certified rate and the revenue you thought you were going
to get would be looking at truth in taxation. It means that we want
to get mentally at the perspective of is the council is considering truth
in taxation every year. It doesn't mean you end up
having to go through Truth in Taxation. Your decision is how much tax revenue do
you need to fund this part of the service.
So in terms of the order and the timeline of things, I want to make
sure we have a chance to talk about that and what that looks like.
Do you have any questions kind of about what I'm, you know,
kind of trying to cover from that perspective? So just
so we're all on the same page, this is kind of what I hoped we
would have had earlier in the year. Uh, I think
our coverage ratio was 32% or 35% going
into this whole conversation, and we started out, let's go 100% coverage,
and now we've kind of dialed it back. I think we'll be at 52% with—
for this year. So going into next year,
as we're having conversations with Chief Knutson and staffing
and going through those metrics,
um, is it possible for us to kind of anticipate
what that revenue might look like from a property tax perspective and
match that up? Like, that, that, that's really the goal, is just
that right out of the gate we're looking at the coverage ratio, we're looking at
that number one. And Chief Knudson is going to,
um, you know, seeing what we've
just kind of went through as a city He's going to be probably pretty measured
in, okay, this is the ask, and as a council, we're going to say this
is safety, and residents now will know that every
dollar they're paying in property tax goes into the safety fund.
So I just want to make sure that we're logistically going to be able to
do that, understanding that the certified tax rate won't really be established until later,
later in the process, but we'll at least know going into that.
If we need to increase a little bit to get another half
a million dollars or decrease because the data center property
tax has taken us way over what the need is for sheriffs, you know,
and we might need to dial that back a little bit. Right.
So it's tying these 2 policies together. The policy where
you said what is the coverage ratio that you want to cover,
and if you're trying to target a minimum of 75% to
that, then that really is where you are coming up
with this is what the existing contract is, and then
we start considering asks or what those staffing needs are,
and then being able to say to cover 75% of that, we are
talking revenue at least at this number.
You agree that is all possible early in the budget process? Absolutely.
possible early in the budget. Yeah. What it can't be or has to happen
is very early on in the budget you have to say regardless we don't care
about the 75% policy, we don't want to consider tax,
truth in taxation at all this year, right. So you're either
using the policy to drive you, it's not, you're not deciding
whether you're doing truth in taxation. You're deciding whether you're following
your policy and the certified tax rate when it comes in The
revenue you said you needed, it either falls within that line or it just means
you now have these public hearings that you do. Or, Kimberly,
perhaps there's something that you know is coming online that
isn't in the diagnostic or in the report so that you
can look at that and say, okay, we are 3 months from this becoming
a reality, right? I like this,
Councilmember Herwish, because it creates an accountability for
council members to be aware of that metrics.
And I mean, I've been here a number of years and this is the first
time I've ever really looked at it from that lens. And that's why I'm grateful
to Councilmember Hewish for kind of pushing me
in that direction to examine it. And I, I also, I'm going to say this,
it's kind of a moving target. That's what you're saying is it's a moving target.
And, and we might think it's X, But it really is going to be Y,
and it can be up or it can be down, right?
Usually it goes up, doesn't usually go down, or it's just flat.
So, but I like that it compels us
to evaluate that and to say, okay, we're still in a good range, or boy,
we're way out of whack on our range. We need to talk about how do
we, how do we fill the gap.
The other thing that it— I'm just thinking about incentive
structures as a council. We're going to want more commercial. Because we know when we
add more rooftops, we need more sheriffs,
more cost. Truth in taxation, that's not fun. At least I didn't
think it was very much fun. Commercial actually brings more calls for
service than residential, though. Well, I guess depending on the commercial,
right? Like the data centers probably aren't getting too many calls. Correct.
So I have a clarifying question, and I know you and I have talked about
this a few times, and sometimes we don't always say things the same way,
so I'm going to make sure that staff and you are on the same page.
Because you said things like, this is a public safety fund.
I want to identify that. And then you said we only covered it at 32%.
Knowing where we're headed, is this only for the
sheriffs to evaluate, or is it all? Because we are way over 32% if
it's for both. So I think it's unfair to say— Yep. Okay, okay.
So, so I want to make sure that now we're bringing in next Yes,
so is this public safety fund? You're not even necessarily bringing
in that. We already have a public safety division that
includes more than just the contract, right? We have dispatch fees that we pay.
We have emergency management services.
So yes, that's a clarification. Is this only the
sheriffs? We have school crossings. Or is this public safety?
School crossing guards. We're talking police and fire. Like, are we trying to meet 75%
of what? What? And 32% is not the correct
number because we're paying more than that now out of property tax because it's 100%
covered for the, for fire out of property tax currently.
Well, now you're bringing in fire, which will be— is it part
of this fund or not? It would be, yeah. I mean, I don't know that
it's drafted that way today, but next year we could
amend the code to include fire. Right now it's just specifically the sheriff's contract.
But next year— It's both. It's public safety. That's what
I'm asking. The code as it's written right now specifies police
services. Even though it says public safety fund, it is written
right now as police services, but with the idea in mind that it could be
amended next year to then keep the title as
public safety, but then change the the scope to include fire.
So why don't we just write it for both now? Is the intent not to
be for both? Well, because we just don't have fire today,
but we could amend it. It can still— even
if we're paying 100% of fire and 50% of— that's still an 85% coverage out
of property tax. If it's legal to put that in the code, I'd be okay
with that. They're both contracts. What's the difference?
That's up to you. That's why I was asking. I think— I mean, it's Yeah,
I agree. I think we were just focused more on the sheriff's contract,
and then next year, once we actually have fire
announced, then we amend the code to include— Would you be okay to
just do public safety? Oh, I think absolutely. There's no reason to bring this back.
Yeah, I think the only issue would just come to,
you know, when we're talking about staffing and
coverage and things like that, we obviously just can't talk about that really
until we know what with UFA once we actually have that under
a contract. Property taxes are covering that. I think it's unfair to say that
100 plus 85, that's more than— I think that's more than what
I— that's my opinion. That's an opinion. That's not— Yeah, I think the weighted average
of where we landed with the sheriff's contract, the 69%
increase and 100 of UFSA, when you do the weighted average,
it's like 77. 86%. Which is why I say it still falls within
that. It would, it would, yep. So we don't need 85%
of just the sheriffs, we need 85% of all public safety? Correct.
Regardless of whether we're in-house or through UFSA?
Correct. Is that,
is that clear? Can I— let me state this, Mayor, because I mean, I think
we're going to have these discussions as we enter into that UFSA discussion.
And so from my perspective, This gives us the
tools to evaluate all public safety and to say, are we in that percentage?
I think it should probably relate to the whole thing, Councilman Pewisch. It sounds like
you agree. And if that's the case, I think that
will help give us a guide too for next year to what do we
do with that rate associated with UFSA. It'll,
it'll give us a guideline to land where we really want to
be. My only question would be, what is the timing on UFSA?
The UFA? So the, the conversation,
and it's been really, uh, with referendums and different things,
it's been a, a little bit harder to nail that down. But we gave
the notice to withdraw. The problem is, is the taxing,
moving that tax over and timing of who collects the tax.
So right now what we've decided is that we would leave
or exit UfSA July 1st,
2028. Sorry, July— January 1st,
2028. Then next year, so 2027 budget
year, just like this year, one year from what we just did, we would do
the Truth in Taxation process to— Establish the rate.
Establish the rate so that if for some reason we
have issues, then we couldn't get out because of the that
people want UFSA to keep charging too much, because that's still possible.
And otherwise, we'll be able to pull it in and people will see the wisdom
in that. If it passes, then we can exit. If we exit too early,
then nobody's taxing at all. And we still want fire coverage,
right? Yeah, we still want to. So, and I'm gonna—
I think that was the layman's term of saying the timing of how that works.
And if Marcus wants to clarify, you're welcome to. Was that a fair enough assessment?
Yeah, I mean, that is my understanding
is that they want it to be on January 1st of whatever year we pull
out. So yeah,
if we aren't able to raise our taxes to cover, that would be problematic for
funding it. So it does make sense to leave, to stay
in UFSA until we've pulled that, done that switch. But let's be clear when
we say if we're unable to raise our taxes, If we raise those taxes,
UFSA is going to lower their tax. I want our residents to hear that.
There's going to be a trade-off there. The net change would be essentially zero
in the first year and go down over time. Or go
down even the first year because of the difference in taxable value, but we have
to get through that. So then the second option that I've already worked on with
the state, and I know Evan and I have talked about it, it's been a
while, is creating legislation that when you have a special service district,
that we don't have to do the entire Truth in Taxation process,
because it is just changing where that tax and how it's
getting paid for. It's not an increase. Right. But I think that right now that
we need to work on that, because it's an increase for one and a decrease
on the other. I don't think that's
an increase overall. So that's something that we will, as they work on
that 5% rule, I've already talked to the bill
sponsor from last year that They've got to have a carve-out for special service districts,
or how do you ever leave? You'd be trapped forever and they could go wild.
So that's, that's, uh, why that timing.
I want to do it sooner, but because the public's done what the public's done,
then it's going to cost us another year of paying way too much to UFA—
UFSA. We love UFA, whoever.
So is it, is it easier— maybe I'll
just ask Evan and And Marcus's question, is it easier to pass it as is
stated right now? Just considering the Sheriff's Office, would it make more sense
for us to— I mean, I can make a motion and amend it
to include fire as well. I don't know how difficult that would be to add
that in. I think if we were to pass it today, I would prefer
to leave it as is. And if we were to change it to include fire,
I would table it and bring it back.
I don't think it's any easier or harder either way, to be honest, because either
way we have to make changes and bring it back, whether it's in 2 weeks
or whether it's in a year.
If I can make just one quick correction too.
If you choose, and I don't know which way you're going on this, If you
choose to, you know, move forward on the ordinance as is
tonight, just after talking with Kimberly, and I've caught
this myself too, is there's one word that we'd need to change in the
motion. So under 3.50.110,
it's at the very end of this code, B was
added. It says the annual summary must be shared with the public in a public
meeting prior to the adoption of the annual tenant It shouldn't say adoption,
it should say acceptance of the annual tentative budget.
So just want to make sure that is clear so that we don't get our
words mixed up as far as what that's supposed to be.
Which, which section was that? That was 3.50. It's the
very last section, 3.50. What was the word
change? From adoption to acceptance. OK,
adoption. Because when the City Council receives the tentative budget, You're not
adopting it, and in a budget you're accepting it. From adoption to accept. Okay.
Adoption to accept. All right.
I'll go ahead and make a motion then. Yeah.
Mayor. There was no public hearing, so if there's no
other discussion, I'm yeah. Okay. All right, Mayor. I'll make a motion that
the City of Eagle Mountain adopt an ordinance
of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, enacting Chapter.
3.50 of the Eagle Mountain Municipal Code establishing property
tax allocations with the change,
the change of the word adoption to acceptance
in Section 3.50.110.
Second. Okay, just clarification,
he moved to adopt the resolution or is it approve? Does that matter? We okay
with adopt? Um, I, I don't have
a preference for adopt or approve the ordinance. It's fine. Okay, when you approve—
do you want me to restate? I'll restate it. No, I just want to make
sure that adopt was okay. Oh, okay. If you're good with that. If he's good
with it, I am. What's your— did you have a question?
Okay, we're good. Uh, motion by Councilmember
Hewish and a second by Councilmember Whiting. Are there any other questions? I think we'll
start the vote with Councilmember Herch. Yes. Councilmember Clark.
Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes. And Councilmember Whiting. Yes.
Okay, that passes. Thank you.
Appreciate the insight and the foresight on getting that thing
through. Yeah, so, all right, we have
just about wrapping up legislative priorities
list. I have one thing I want to add. And I spoke to Council Member
Wood today, and there was something that I said that's a good thing for this
list, and I forgot what it was. So if you remember— Can I, can I
add one thing, Mayor? Oh, are we going to let John do his magic first?
You're welcome to talk about it, and then you can follow. If you're ready,
go ahead. Yeah, right now we're working on
the legislative priorities for next season
as they're working through the legis— the interim session right now. So we haven't really
moved on your council priorities for the city stuff that I'm working on. I have
to reach out, reach back to everybody and see how they're doing with the other
part of the list. So not much to report other than that. And I
have met with, I think, all of you now regarding the list
except Melissa. So we're almost done with it.
Yes, she did say after— she did say after the 12th, after another meeting we
have So is
there anything that you need to add to the list? Yeah, I would like to
add something, John, and see how the council— see what the council's temperament is to
do this. We've had this discussion before, and I think there's going to be broad
support. But I'd like to put this on the list that we
do whatever it is we need to do to dedicate or to rename
the wildlife migration corridor
Migration Corridor as the Todd A. Black Memorial Wildlife Migration Corridor. I just don't want
to see that get lost. We're coming up on the 1-year anniversary of his— of
our losing him, and I just want to make sure that we do that and
we begin to refer to it in those terms. If the council agrees with me,
I agree with it. Do we need to make a motion to add that or
direct staff or something? So moved.
So seconded.
Okay,
so there's a motion by Councilmember Wright
and a second by Councilmember Clark to add to the priority list the name change
of the corridor. And we'll start the vote with Councilmember Clark.
Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes. Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Hewish.
Yes. And so that's— it's a great action, and I
don't mind it being on the list. I'm just trying to think if it sits
there for too long, If there's an easier way, I mean, this isn't
it's not code. This is just no, we just put it on the agenda.
Yeah, and my thought process is this, Mayor. Maybe we can erect some signs.
We can you know put them on some of the fencing that he erected.
Just something to recognize and name it, and then change it
on our maps so that doesn't just show up as the deer migration corridor or
the wildlife corridor. It shows up as the Todd A. Black Memorial Wildlife Corridor.
My point was is there's not a lot for. We just need it to come
on an agenda to change the— Whatever you want to do with
it, Big John, let's make it happen. So yeah, I'll put it on top of
this. I have till the 12th to meet with Melissa, so the other one can
sit and wait for a little bit. 13th. Actually, the 14th.
The 12th is a holiday. So that's—
I know there was a couple other things that we— oh, I want to— and
I'll come to Councilmember Clark, but for Councilmember For Hewish's sake,
I don't know that I've heard, but you brought up earlier the code
for parking trailers. We should probably get an update or
whatever on that. Go ahead, Councilmember Clark. Or do you have— Do
I have an update on it? Yeah, just for us to talk
about it. Is it on our list yet? We put it on the 4th.
I think it should be on the list. Okay, so it's just a— Is it
on the list? Follow-up. I'd have to check. I don't remember seeing that. If I
could jump in on this one. So it was put on the list. It was
created, a code was created. It did go through Planning
Commission and it did come to City Council and then it was denied. So this
would be an action to put it back on the list if that's
what we want to do. Well, so it was denied prior to going back on
the list. Before the last election, when it was denied, correct?
So then it got back on the list. And so I think what we need
to do is—that's what I'm getting at—is I think we just bring the bring that
code back. Yes, because I don't think there's a ton of
staff work because we've already done the staff work. Yes. Do you do
you want it to come on as a work session discussion amongst the council first
before running it through planning commission and everything and doing noticing?
Or do you want just to start? I was. I think so, because the reason
it was denied is it wasn't ready. So there's obviously some talk, but— Maybe bring
it back in a working session and we can fine-tune that a little bit.
I know I'm new and there's been a lot of thought put
into that previously, but I think the issue still is persisting.
And initially this came up from residents with
support from staff. So we're behind it.
I think at the time that it came up, there was residents that were in
favor of it, and that's how it got onto the legislative priority list. And then
at the time it came back to the council, there was residents against it,
and for different reasons. And I don't
question that at all. It's just we're happy to— we serve with a pleasure.
But I do think that we already had— if we still have that, we had
it written. It's just a matter of bringing it back for discussion. So let's— if—
I think that's why, as far as the list, That's why I brought it up,
is if we just have Lacey pull that
back up, put it on our next work session, and we'll,
yeah, we'll just move forward. So that one will kind
of give you a little relief, 'cause I think we've got it. Councilmember Clark.
Okay. I shared some code
for annual budget metrics and budget in brief with,
it started as an email from Councilmember Hewish, to like me and a
couple staff members. So I don't know if John's on that email or not,
but if he's not, would someone please forward it to him?
Um, I also am grateful that we're going to be taking a look
at the business licensing for home-based business. One of the other
things that has come up with different residents
is the, the idea of agritourism.
There have been applications, or at least questions about
pumpkin patch and just different things like that,
or farm-to-table dinners, or farm—
like sourdough classes, and just different things like that. So with
the support of council, I would like for us to consider adding
agritourism code to our
legislative priorities list, and hopefully economic development
team can help kind of guide that a little bit. And then the
last one that I wanted to check on is Justice Court.
This got added to our list,
I want to say like February 2024.
Can I jump in on that? Yeah. I actually was, during our work session,
I was communicating with Chris Karn and Paul Binns about
this topic, and that's what it was that I said I couldn't remember. So in—
You're welcome. Yeah, thank you for— because I was like, I have to talk about
this. In Lehigh, they have somewhat canceled their Justice
Corps. And the council, it's been a— if you listen to their meetings, it's been
a little bit of a wrestle over there on the whole Justice
Corps. Mayor Binns called me and said, hey, would you guys be
interested in joining us and doing something different? Because this just isn't working.
I mentioned, you know, we've already been kind of looking at doing something with Saratoga.
Even if it's district or if it's municipal,
Saratoga thinks they pay way too much for for what
they have, and I don't want to say they hate
it, but it's it's it's expensive
to do it for just their city. So I mentioned that
I would bring it up tonight as I was trying to get through that,
and and I forgot. But there there's a great desire.
At least the 3 mayors that have talked about it, to either—
it can be municipal court, but 3 interlocal, and we could house
it. I believe— I haven't talked to Mark, obviously, but Chris isn't aware.
And, uh, we could house it at Saratoga. We could do
a separate building, you know, build a, you know, do, do a fund and bond
for its own court. But I'm just curious what the— because of like what you're
saying, we know that there's a need. The public wants Police force, things like that.
Do we want to— I, I think we for sure should explore those
options, and I get that it's a pretty significant
cost. Um, even before we do that, I know that there's
something that has to be done with our code
to enter it into some sort of system so people can get
ticketed for something. So I'm saying that so Chief Knutson
can tell us what that is. So in the interim, while we're waiting for a
justice court to get established, we can do whatever it takes so
that we can actually start enforcing our laws. That's all
I'm asking for is enforcement. So, so it would be adding the bail schedule to—
so that our ordinances are within the
ability for the master offense table.
Okay, so moved. That's all I want, you guys. I want it
done. So I think by the end of this This one may be a little
different because I don't know that it's necessarily John's job. In my opinion,
I think I'd rather instruct Ben to work with Mark and Jason.
But can we get that to happen so
we can enforce our law? Well, if not, you've got the power to fire him.
I don't know, just tell him to do it. No, I— to
me, in a lot of ways, the legislative affairs person is It's their role
to pick up the football that we've laid out and run with it until it's
done. But I also think the relationships with our city managers is where this is
gonna happen. But I think the other cities
already have their stuff entered in, 'cause they already have their own police forces.
It's the disconnect within ours. Oh, we're talking about 2 different things. That's what I'm
talking about, yeah. We're talking about 2 different things, sorry. I apologize. You're talking about
the bell schedule. Yes. So yes, that is something that,
It's actually probably our fee schedules.
You can put it on the list, but it's going to fall under the
recorder's office or in the— I know Finn
was running with this one. We'll just have to figure out how we're going to
move forward with it. So that's a separate issue than what I was talking
about. Yes. So, but in the meantime,
that's what I'm saying. Yes, let's explore every option we can with our neighboring
cities. But the thing that's holding us back from enforcing stuff is that master
list and entering that into the system. And I just want to make that
happen by the end of this year, please and thank you. So is there— is
there support on this one? This is something that's been on
the back burner for me just because I haven't had time to address it,
and that I was planning on assigning to the new attorney.
So I'm happy to assign that to whoever that person is. So is that
better than the priority list? Because I think— Is that something that we could hire
or secure the services of a contractor to do? Like, what does it entail?
Like, what are we looking at? Because— It's just reviewing the code,
finding, you know, everywhere where it's set where it creates a criminal offense.
And then you have to get the code, and then you have to create
language, charging language for them to put into
the court system. So it's working with the Administrative Office of the
Courts to get that into their system,
so that, to the master offense table, so that in
their computer program, they can just pull it up. It'll say,
you know, Eagle Mountain Municipal Code or whatever, you know, Section 6.05020,
animal violations, and then it'll have charging language,
and it'll automatically be able to reference that. Ben's gonna solve all
my problems right now. It would be able to have a dropdown box or whatever
they have in their computer program. So it's not something that I can— I'm
aware that there's actually a state law requiring it. It's just something that
the kind of the fickle nature of the AOC that they require it.
I've been through this once before. It is a fairly detailed
and tedious assignment, so it may take some time, but it's not something that we
can't work to accomplish. Either through an assignment with internal staff or looking
at options, because other cities enter these things as well, and maybe we can contract
that out. We will look at those options and move forward. Thank you.
And Kimberly had Teams'd me just to let me know
that Richard is looking into the Justice Court cost right now, so that assignment has
been given. So I don't think
that necessarily— unless you want it for tracking, I don't know that it needs to
go on John's list. Justice Court has been on there since since February of '24.
So unless somebody has moved to remove it in a meeting
that I wasn't at, which didn't happen because I'm at every meeting,
it needs to happen. So let's just make it happen. That one's good. And then
as far as the justice court, I think that's fine if he's looking into it,
but I do think a conversation with the managers is going to
go a long ways. Um, the 2 managers as well as the county, because what
we were kind of looking forward is, uh, that precinct type of— Well, do we—
yeah, do we do a district court or municipal
But I think that's why you talk to them to see what their appetite is
and then talk to the county about which route. So that's what I'm curious
about. I don't know what their appetite is. I would be happy to do that.
And I know Jason's gonna— his eyes are gonna be like,
uh, it's gonna be nice. Jason and Mark and I get along just
well. Yeah, so now anything
else for legislative priorities? There was a comment from Councilmember Clark
about agritourism. What did you want to get put on?
Um, I— we've had people ask about pumpkin
patches, Christmas tree type lots in a neighborhood setting,
and farm-to-table things where
they could have a one-time thing where they use farm food
to create a special dinner and just make it a ticketed event.
Um, I'm not necessarily supportive of making a
Christmas tree stand in the middle of a neighborhood, but I'm definitely
willing to look at the farm-to-table stuff and potentially even a pumpkin
patch in the right area. So, um,
I would love council and staff to work together
along with our businesses and people within
our community that have the desire to offer agritourism and make it
epic, because I think it's yet another thing that Eagle Mountain Do
we really have the resources to target that as one of our main objectives?
That's my question. I'm not going to disagree with you that there could
be some benefit to it. But I mean, we sit here and we moan
and groan about the fact that we're not working on the Justice Court, and we
task people with, let's figure out how to do a pumpkin patch. I just think
we have to be careful in the asks that we make. I agree with
what you're saying, but in a lot of ways, agritourism is a tourism is a
component of economic development. And looking at
what other cities have already done and bringing that for
a discussion item doesn't feel like it will take away from the
duties of the other people who are working on code. It feels like it's more
of an economic development department
working with the state's Office of Tourism to find out
what best practices are. But if we want to put it on a back burner
for a while, I'm okay with that too. It's just— okay.
I'm fine putting it on there, but making
sure staff is sort of prioritizing what is on there. I mean, I'm sort of
fine to put it on there so it's on the radar still.
So this is very déjà vu.
If you think agritourism, you think things like the
Cache Valley Cheese down in Beaver, right? And getting your ice cream cone. You think
of the Red Barn. in Santaquin with— Red Barn. At Rolly's Red
Barn. You think of Maddox Steakhouse up
in Perry. You know, those are farm-to-fork, or they're growing their beef right there
and all that kind of a thing. Where— and having been through
this, like I said, it's very déjà vu— where it
is the most successful is when you have an industry like Basin Fruit
Growers or Cache Valley Uh,
their, their, the cheese and the milk production and dairies and whatnot,
when they come in and work with the city partnership hand in
hand to try to bring that forward, as opposed to a residential
or a one-off type of thing, which is, uh, so we're happy
to make it work and happy to bring code, and, and, and I've
got a lot of experience in this area. Um, uh,
we just want to make sure we're targeting the right thing, and do we have
farms in place that we are trying to take our milk and
turn it into, you know, stops on a freeway, that type
of thing. You know, that's, that's where it can be a destination. There's no
doubt. Um, I think one of the things that I'm thinking about is
the fact that I know of at least 2 farms right now that
are operating within our city limits that are already doing things like these,
and there's no code that addresses what they're doing. And I think
it's useful for us to look at that because everything's
fine until a neighbor complains to Neighborhood Improvement about it.
And, um, if it's something that council
needs to work on code for it, maybe Councilmember Whiting and I can
take it and run with it. I, I just— we have the issue
in our city right now, and I think,
um, yes, we have to prioritize stuff, but we also have to look at the
My personal preference with the small body here and knowing
that it's a little bit split, I would rather that that's a council
priority, knowing that we are thin-staffed. And if everything's priority,
nothing's a priority. That'd be my preference. But if you
do want to pursue putting
it on a list and having staff work on it, then I'm fine with that.
I think that's a good idea. Councilmember Clark and I will work on it.
We'll bring you— we'll bring something to you, and we'll make it specific to
what's already existing in the city. Thank you. Okay, yeah, if we can do that,
that helps our staff load, I think, a lot. Uh, so anything
else for John? I think we're good. All right then.
Uh, I know you mentioned the seniors, uh, you met with them. Is there anything
else? Can I— I just— I want— they've rescheduled the chili cook-off
for October 26th at 5 PM. I just want to invite the council,
and they're going to have a kind of a Halloween-themed party there.
But you have to come and prepare your chili at the senior center or here
at the city hall, because I learned that you can't, you can't
make it at home and bring it. You have to cook it in a commercial
kitchen that's been checked and all that good stuff. So I'll give you
more details, but that's October 26th at 5 PM. if you just put that on
your calendars. And I've asked Dawn to send out an invite to each of you
so you're aware of that. That's all I have, Mayor. Thank you.
Okay, did you have any reports for liaison stuff?
Shop Fest is coming up, I think you mentioned, right? Well, that's Craig's report,
but the American Legion didn't meet this last
month, and I think maybe we
should look into that. I do, while they're not meeting,
I think we need to progress forward with
the veterans breakfast because I think that's something that we
as a city need to host and
just give it as a gift to our veterans and military families
in our community and kind of take that back under our wing. For some reason
I was thinking that was in the spring, but is it in November 11th.
Yeah, and I think this year it's like on November 14th or something,
'cause it's the Saturday immediately following the 11th. So— If
there's no plans for that, then I think we should work with Dawn, and I
think she's worked on— I think it's on Dawn's radar. I just
want to keep it top of mind so that we're all preparing
for it. Once upon a time, the city council would
go and make the pancakes and help make the food and serve.
And we'd bring Boy Scouts in to help wash dishes and everything else.
And then somehow along the line, it ended up being a bunch of
veterans serving other veterans. And I think the point of the Veterans Breakfast
was for the community to serve our veterans. So. I've been
to that event for many, many years. Yes. I've cooked a lot of pancakes and
bacon. Any other reports? I got grease on my shoes.
Youth Council, anything? Youth Council's meeting this week,
and I'll be there with them. And, uh, Chamber's doing awesome. We've already talked about
Shop Fest, but they're just crushing it. They're doing such a
great job.
Did Melissa already talk about, uh, liaison? I know
the community services— oh, thanks. The Community Development Board presented
tonight. Yeah, community Services Board, they presented tonight.
There's a list that they're going to bring back. I don't think we got it
on our working agenda, but they have a list of projects within the city.
We also had some reported initial RAP tax revenue.
I don't know if we're ready to discuss that. I think
Steve has some numbers there, but it sounded like the RAP
tax revenue received is coming in faster than maybe what was initially
I knew it. Communicated when that
was being voted on. So positive things happening there.
But I believe in the next working session, Mayor, if we could add the
Community Services Board to present the list of topics
so they can get some guidance from the council on where
to put their energy and focus to start laying down some of these projects
in our city. Let me ask you a question. specific like that,
I'm fine if it needs to be. But are you giving me a little leeway
to say put it on as soon as I can, or does it have to
be next meeting? They're kind of— they're,
they're doing everything at a full sprint. So like, I just don't know
what the workload is yet because I want to make sure that if it's— if
the council brings it, then I'm going to put it on, and it might be
prepared for— I will say that they wanted to put it— they want it they
wanted to request putting it on today's agenda, but because of everything
else, they were okay with putting it on a subsequent agenda. So I would
say as soon as you can humanly get it on there, Mayor. You make a
note if there's room in the next agenda, and if not, we can make sure
we— 15 minutes. 15 minutes.
Okay, um, say again? Good for motion.
Yep. Wait, we got to make a Yeah, I move to—
I move the council adjourn to a closed session pursuant to Section 52-4-205,
subsection 1 of the Utah Code Annotated.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting, second by Councilmember Hewish.
Councilmember Clark? Yes. Councilmember Wright? Yes. Councilmember Whiting?
Yes. Councilmember Hewish? Yes. Okay, that passes.
At 9:06, we will adjourn to closed session. Fantastic.
All right, it is 9:47, and we're back in our city council
meeting. And if everybody's okay, we'll entertain a motion. Motion to adjourn.
Second. Okay, we have a motion to adjourn by Councilmember Whiting and a second
by Councilmember Wright. All in favor? Aye. That's unanimous,
and we are adjourned at 9:47.